WE CAN GET ALL RIGHT. WE ARE
MEETING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY HAS BEGUN JUST FOR A
COUPLE OF QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS.
WE HAVE 21 BILLS ON THE
CALENDAR. AB 2419 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA BY THE
AUTHOR. TWO BILLS ARE ON CONSENT
AB 2807 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VÆ
VALLAPUDUA AND AB 3083 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY, IN THIS
COMMITTEE, THE AUTHOR WILL
PRESENT THEIR BILL AT THE
PODIUM. WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY
AT THE MICROPHONE OUTSIDE THE
WELL. EACH BILL CAN HAVE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. EACH OF THOSE
WITNESSES GET TWO MINUTES EACH
AND WE WILL TIME THEM AFTER THE
MAIN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TESTIFY. WE WILL ALL WE WILL
TAKE ALL ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. ME TWO'S STATE YOUR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE TO
KEEP OUR BUSINESS BUSY HEARING
GOING. IF YOU ARE A ME TO PLEASE
BE LINED UP AND READY TO GO
AGAIN. WE HAVE 21 BILLS ON THE
CALENDAR. WE TAKE AUTHORS AS
THEY ARRIVE TO BE AS EFFICIENT
AS POSSIBLE, AND WITH THAT, I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR A ROLL CALL TO
SEE IF WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM.
WAHAB. HERE. WAHAB. HERE. SATO.
SATO. HERE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
HERE. SKINNER WIENER. SO WE HAVE
A QUORUM. AND NOW WE ARE GOING
TO BE WAITING FOR AUTHORS, WE
HAVE A MOTION, BUT, BY SENATOR
SATO FOR MOVING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL
, PLEASE, WAHAB? AYE, AYE. SATO.
SATO. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE SKINNER. WIENER ALL RIGHT.
CONSENTS ON CALL, AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR AUTHORS TO SHOW UP.
2064. ALL RIGHT. FILE NUMBER
SEVEN, AB 2064 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES. SAWYER WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. 2064
WILL ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE INTERDICTION.
INTERDICTION GRANT PROGRAM. THE
BILL IS AMONG 14 PRIORITIES
IDENTIFIED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AS IT RELATES TO
THE REPARATIONS PACKAGE. THIS
BILL WOULD ADMINISTER THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY, I SHOULD SAY,
AND WOULD ENSURE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY DRIVEN SOLUTIONS TO
DECREASE VIOLENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND NEIGHBORHOODS. AS OPPOSED TO
INCARCERATION. THE FUNDS WILL BE
SECURED THROUGH AN
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE SAVINGS
FROM ANY FUTURE PRISON CLOSURES
WITHIN THE STATE. BY ALLOCATING
RESOURCES TO THESE PREVENTIVE
PREVENTATIVE INITIATIVES, WE
REDUCE INCARCERATION EITHER FOR
EVEN FURTHER AND FOCUS TO
FINDING ON SOLUTIONS TO CRIME
BEYOND INCARCERATION OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. 2064 ALLOWS THE
TRUE REHABILITATIVE
REHABILITATION THROUGH PUTTING
AN EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY AND
VICTIMS IMPACTED, GIVES THEM A
VOICE, AND REDUCES EXPENDITURES
ACCRUED ON IMPRISONMENT WHICH
HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES? THANK YOU, CAN WE GET
OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES? MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, PAUL YODER,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY AND SUPPORT LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, JENNIFER ROWE WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OPPO LEAD OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ME TWO'S OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. MOVING IT TO MEMBERS.
SENATOR SERRANO HI. MY ONLY
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IF YOU VISIT THE PRISON AND, AND
LOOK AT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS,
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO TO
REHABILITATE AND, EDUCATE AND
GET PEOPLE READY TO COME BACK
INTO SOCIETY AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM, THIS MONEY COULD BE
USED FOR THAT BECAUSE THOSE
FACILITIES ARE WHOLLY
INADEQUATE. AND I WOULD RATHER
SEE THE MONEY AND THE SAVINGS
EITHER BE SPLIT. SO SOME OF IT
GOES TO THE EDUCATION OUTSIDE.
BUT ALSO TO BRING THE FACILITIES
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY LACKING
WITHIN THE SYSTEM. UP TO, AN UP
TO SPEED SO THAT THEY CAN BE
EFFECTIVE IN, IN TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH OUR, WITH OUR, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INCARCERATED AND
SO, I APPRECIATE WANTING TO STOP
IT BEFOREHAND, BUT I ALSO WOULD
LIKE US TO, HAVE BILLS THAT WILL
TAKE IN MIND BOTH OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND WHAT THE
GOALS ARE, BECAUSE THIS LEAVES
ONE OF THOSE GOALS BEHIND, AND,
AND I KNOW THERE IS A DIRE NEED
FOR FUNDING, WITHIN THE PRISONS
TO CREATE THE FACILITIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT THEY DESPERATELY
WANT TO USE. SO I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING TODAY. WOULD YOU MAKE
A COURTESY MOTION SO IT COULD BE
ON FILE? I'LL MAKE A COURTESY
MOTION SO WE CAN GET IT ON FILE.
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A COURTESY
MOTION BY SENATOR SERRATA. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, AND THIS
IS PREVENTATIVE. WE'RE TRYING TO
STOP IT ON THE FRONT END VERSUS
ADDRESSING IT ON THE BACK END,
WHICH IS WE DO IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM. AND DESPITE THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
ALLOCATED FOR REHABILITATION,
IT'S FAILING MISERABLY, AS WE
ALL KNOW. SO TO CONTINUE TO
THROW GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD INTO
A BAD SITUATION CLEARLY HASN'T,
PRODUCED THE RESULTS THAT WE
WANT. WE'RE TRYING TO, AGAIN, DO
IT ON THE FRONT END TO PREVENT
FOLKS FROM GOING TO PRISON,
PREVENT FOLKS FROM NEEDING TO BE
REHABILITATED ONCE INCARCERATED.
SO ON THAT NOTE, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SERRANO. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
ITEM SEVEN AB 2064 JONES-SAWYER
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB I SATO. NO
SATO. NO. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
SKINNER. WIENER. TADPOLES ON
CALL. FELDMAN SAID ONE OF HIS
SAID HIS PERSON.
SIX.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE OUR NEXT
PRESENTER FILED. ITEM 21, AB
3241 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
THEIR. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING. IS IT ON? OKAY.
PERFECT. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. AB 3241 SETS CLEAR
AND COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
K9 PROGRAMS WITH THE GOAL OF
UNIFORMITY, ACCOUNTABILITY, AND
EXCELLENCE IN THE USE OF POLICE
CANINES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ARE
SAFELY DEPLOYING CANINES AND
PRIORITIZING THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND CANINE HANDLERS,
MAKING CALIFORNIA A LEADER ON
THIS ISSUE WITH ME TODAY. TODAY
TO TESTIFY OUR REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE
POLICE OFFICERS RESEARCH. I
CAN'T EVEN SPEAK. I RAN OVER
HERE AND THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. TWO MINUTES, BUDDY.
I'LL BE QUICK. CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHAN FELDMAN, CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
CANINES ARE IMPORTANT TOOL. THEY
PROVIDE. AWARENESS THAT
OTHERWISE WITHOUT THEM, OFFICERS
WOULD NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DETECT CERTAIN THREATS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNDETERMINED,
WITH THEIR SENSE OF SMELL,
HEARING, THEY PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TIME, DISTANCE
AND SPACE WHICH GIVE, YOU KNOW,
SORRY. CHANCES TO DE-ESCALATE
THE SITUATION. STATISTICS SHOW
IN OVERWHELMING CASES, THE
DEPLOYMENT OF A K-9 RESULTS IN,
SURRENDER OR LAWFUL COMPLIANCE.
IN OVER 90% OF THE SITUATIONS
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY UTILIZED
IN, USE OF FORCE INSTANCES WHILE
RARE, DO OCCUR, AND THERE'S
ALWAYS ROOM TO DO BETTER. THIS
BILL WILL IMPROVE THE PROGRAMS
BY STANDARDIZING GUIDELINES,
CERTIFYING TRAINING, AND
REQUIRING UNIFORM REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE STATE,
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS ONE, THE CONSULTANT
FOR THE WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE YOUR NEXT
WITNESS? I'LL GIVE A ME TWO ON
BEHALF OF POREC WHO'S NOT HERE.
OKAY AND THEN DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION? THE LEAD
OPPOSITION FIRST. MAYBE NO ONE
THERE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE. OKAY. NO WORRIES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. MY NAME IS CHRIS BURBANK.
I'M THE FORMER POLICE CHIEF IN
SALT LAKE CITY, UTAH, VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE MAJOR CITY
CHIEFS ORGANIZATION AND
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE INSTITUTE. WE SHOULD
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT THIS BILL
LACKS LEGAL STANDARD. AT A
MINIMUM, AB 3241 SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE THAT
PROHIBITS CANINE USE FOR
RESISTING OR THREATENING, RIGHT.
THAT LIMITS CANINES TO ONLY
SITUATION WHERE IT'S A PERSON IS
SUSPECTED OF A FELONY INVOLVING
THREATS OF SERIOUS BODILY INJURY
OR DEATH, AND PROHIBITS THE USE
OF CANINES FOR CROWD CONTROL,
ESPECIALLY CROWD CONTROL. THIS
HAS BEEN THE STANDARD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FOR 25 YEARS, RIGHT? THE
IACP RECOMMENDS THAT CANINES
SHOULD NOT BE USED, ESPECIALLY
NOT CANINES THAT THEIR REACTION
IS TO BITE. THERE ARE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CANINES.
POLICE DOGS THAT ARE TRAINED TO
APPREHEND AS WELL AS TO DETECT
IN WHICH THEIR RESPONSE IS NOT
ABIDING MECHANISM, BUT A BARKING
MECHANISM OR A CHASING MECHANISM
. THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
REASONABLE AMENDMENTS AND REALLY
ARE THE BARE NECESSITY IN MY
EXPERIENCE AS A POLICE CHIEF.
GOING BACK 1516 YEARS, WE
CHANGED THE STANDARD BY WHICH WE
USED POLICE CANINES IN WHICH
THEIR RESPONSE WAS TO BITE
INDIVIDUALS. ONE IT IS A BAD
LOOK FOR POLICING, BUT IF YOU
IMAGINE THE IMPACT OF ANOTHER
AND TEACHING AN ANIMAL TO BITE A
HUMAN BEING, ESPECIALLY IN
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT DON'T RISE TO
THE NECESSITY OF THIS LEVEL OF
USE OF FORCE, GOOD POLICY IS
GENERATED OUT OF LEGISLATIVE
BODIES CREATING RULES AND
STANDARDS BY WHICH THE POLICE
OPERATE, AND THEN THE POLICE
ADHERING TO THOSE LEGAL
STANDARDS THAT ARE SET FORTH.
THANK YOU. I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CHRISTY LOPEZ, AND FOR
OVER A DECADE I WAS A DEPUTY
CHIEF IN THE US DOJ CIVIL RIGHTS
DIVISION, WHERE I LED POLICE
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND I NOW
TEACH COURSES ON POLICING AND
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE AT GEORGETOWN
LAW. WHILE I SUPPORT LEGISLATION
IN THIS AREA, I AM COMPELLED TO
TESTIFY AGAINST, IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 3241, BECAUSE THIS BILL
ALONE, OR IN COMBINATION WITH
2042, FAILS TO SET CLEAR AND
STRICT LIMITATIONS ON THE USE OF
POLICE DOGS. MY EXPERIENCE
REVIEWING K-9 PRACTICES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAS MADE CLEAR THAT
WITHOUT CLEAR LEGISLATIVE LIMITS
, AB 3241 WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
CONTINUE USING POLICE DOGS TO
INFLICT UNNECESSARY HARM ON
PEOPLE POSING NO THREAT TO
OFFICERS OR OTHERS SUSPECTED OF
ONLY MINOR CRIMES OR NO CRIMES
AT ALL, OR IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. IN SHORT, AB 3241
COMPLETELY FAILS TO ADDRESS THE
LIFE ALTERING HARMS THAT BROUGHT
POLICE DOGS INTO THE
LEGISLATURE'S SPOTLIGHT IN THE
FIRST PLACE. ANY BILL PASSED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT SEEKS TO
REGULATE THE USE OF POLICE DOGS
MUST HAVE EXPLICIT STATUTORY
MINIMUMS. AT A MINIMUM, CANINE
DEPLOYMENT SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
SITUATIONS WHERE THE INDIVIDUAL
IS SUSPECTED OF HAVING COMMITTED
A VIOLENT FELONY. THE USE IS
PROPORTIONAL TO THE IMMINENT
THREAT, AND WHERE LESSER FORCE
HAS BEEN FOUND, TRIED, HAS BEEN
TRIED OR FOUND TO BE INFEASIBLE.
LASTLY, WHILE DATA COLLECTION
AND ANALYSIS REGARDING CANINE
USE IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT, THE
BILL'S DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS WILL FAIL TO
PRODUCE THE DATA NEEDED FOR
FUTURE POLICY MAKING. THE BILL
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO REQUIRE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BE
REQUIRED TO REPORT ON AMONG
OTHER DATA, ACCIDENTAL BITES BY
CANINES. THE REASONS FOR AND
OUTCOMES OF CANINE DEPLOYMENTS,
AND THE COST OF MAINTAINING K9
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE COST AND
OFFICER TIME, AND IN LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS. WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION, THE LEGISLATURE,
POLICE DEPARTMENTS, AND THE
PUBLIC WILL NOT HAVE THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO MAKE
INFORMED, RATIONAL DECISIONS
ABOUT USING CANINES FOR FORCE
WITHOUT EXPLICIT STRICT
STATUTORY STANDARDS, AB 3241
WILL DO MORE HARM THAN GOOD,
INVITING UNJUSTIFIABLE USES OF
POLICE DOGS TO CONTINUE. BUT
NOW, WITH A STAMP OF APPROVAL
FROM THE LEGISLATURE. FOR THESE
REASONS, I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE NO ON AB 3241. THANK YOU,
ME TOOS EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION, STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION, AND WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE GARRETT
HAMILTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION,
WE SUPPORT. BRENDAN, UP ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, JENNIFER ROWE WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS, THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE, THE
LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, AND
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT ASSOCIATION,
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
GEORGE BRANDT, TH¤U ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION ASIAN LAW
ALLIANCE, AND THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON, FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL LOZANO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CRIME VICTIMS
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. ROXANA
GONZALEZ, INITIATE JUSTICE AND
OPPOSITION. KATRINA REECE, WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. YOLANDA NEVER READY
WITH. I'M AN OUTSIDE ORGANIZER
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. SORRY.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THIS
OR SUPPORT THIS BILL? SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, SEEING
NO SENATOR BRADFORD. YES, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND I'M
GRAPPLING WITH THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE I KNOW THE HISTORY OF
WHY DOGS WERE FIRST UTILIZED IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND IT WAS DUE
TO SLAVERY AND THEN PURSUING
RUNAWAY SLAVES. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA, MOST OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE MAULED BY THE
POLICE DOGS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS A DOG
LOVER WHO SPENT 20 YEARS OF MY
LIFE TRAINING GERMAN SHEPHERDS,
SZCZECIN, WHICH IS A DISCIPLINE
OF TRACKING OBEDIENCE AND
PROTECTION, MANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS SIDE BY SIDE WERE
POLICE OFFICERS, AND I HEARD THE
STORIES OF HOW THEY LET THEIR
DOGS LOOSE ON INDIVIDUALS AND
LAUGHED AS THEY MAULED
INDIVIDUALS. SO DO WE NEED TO
REIN THIS IN? YES. BUT AGAIN, I
HAVE TO ECHO THE CONCERNS THAT
THE POLICE CHIEF STATED AS TO
WHEN DOGS SHOULD BE DEPLOYED,
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE FOR A BIDING
PROCESS. WE JUST SAW JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO. NOT HEARING
CALIFORNIA, BUT, I FORGOT TO
STATE WHERE HE CLEARLY SAW
INDIVIDUALS STOP ROADSIDE. THE
GUY WAS COMPLIANT AND ONE OF THE
OFFICERS RELEASED A DOG, AND
THAT DOG BEGAN TO MAUL THIS
INDIVIDUAL SO, SO BADLY THAT
EVEN THE OFFICERS WERE
SCREAMING, SAYING, BRING THE DOG
BACK, RETRIEVE THE DOG BACK. SO
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE SOME MORE
GUIDELINES, AND I'M PRETTY SURE
I, A FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS NOW
RETIRED FROM LAPD, I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW THE QUESTION WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE DOG YOU RELEASE A
DOG AND THAT DOG IS INJURED?
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE OF AN
OFFICER IF THAT HAPPENS? WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE DOG IS INJURED?
YES, I MEAN, HOW DO POLICE
OFFICERS RESPOND IF THE DOG IS
INJURED? I CAN HAVE MY WITNESS
TESTIFY AS TO THAT. YEAH. I'LL
SAY AFTER EVERY INCIDENT,
THERE'S A REVIEW AND AN
ANALYSIS. IF THE DOG IS INJURED
OR IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF,
EXCESSIVE FORCE OR ANY TYPE OF
ABUSE THAT OCCURS UNLAWFUL,
THERE'S A REVIEW. THE DOGS
PULLED OFF, RETRAINED,
REEVALUATED, REASSESSED BEFORE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PUT BACK INTO
THE FIELD. THERE'S THE DOG IS
INJURED BY THE ASSAILANT THAT
YOU'RE RELEASED ON TO. HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT
SAME WAY ATTACKING A OFFICER?
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND? I MEAN,
EVERY INCIDENT IS GOING TO BE
DYNAMIC, AND IT'S GOING TO BE
DEPENDENT UPON THE LEVEL OF
FORCE THAT'S BEING USED AGAINST,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE BODIES OF
LAW THAT REGULATE WHAT TYPE OF
FORCE CAN BE USED. WE WENT
THROUGH A YEAR AND A HALF LONG
DEBATE HERE ABOUT THE USE OF
FORCE REQUIREMENTS FOR DEPLOYING
ANY TYPE OF USE OF FORCE,
INCLUDING A CANINE. SO ALL OF
THAT IS APPLICABLE HERE.
PROPORTIONAL FORCE IS REQUIRED.
IT MUST BE SERIOUS. IT MUST MEET
THE THREAT THAT'S BEING,
PRESENTED. YOU CAN'T JUST USE,
YOU KNOW, OVERWHELMING FORCE
AGAINST SOMEBODY IF THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY PRESENTING THAT LEVEL
OF THREAT OR THREAT AND
RESISTANCE. SO ALL OF THAT IS IN
PLAY. IT'S IN PLACE. YOU KNOW, I
WOULD DISAGREE SLIGHTLY WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE. THERE
ARE THOSE STANDARDS. WE SPENT A
LONG TIME DEVELOPING THOSE
STANDARDS THAT DO APPLY TO THE
USE OF CANINES. AND WE ALL
AGREED TO WHAT WAS SET FORTH
BOTH IN STATUTE AND IN POLICY.
AND TRAINING. THIS IS NOW
SPECIFIC TO THE USE OF THE
CANINE. SO IT'S GETTING EVEN
MORE DETAILED AND MORE GRANULAR
ON THESE EXACT TYPE OF PROGRAMS.
SO AGAIN, THERE ARE
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATIONS
ALREADY IN PLACE. WE'RE DOING
MORE NOW. WE'VE GOT A COMPANION
BILL THAT WE'VE WORKED, YOU
KNOW, WITH THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT PROPORTIONAL
FORCE REQUIREMENT, WHILE IT'S
NOT IN OUR BILL, YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR IT PRESENTED BY THE SECOND
BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE HERE,
LOOKING LIKE, RIGHT AFTER OURS.
SO ALL OF THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE, AND WE
DID HAVE A LEGAL STANDARD THAT
WE TRIED TO FIGURE OUT IN THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE, YOU KNOW,
OPTED TO REMOVE IT BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T QUITE GET THERE. BUT
THE LEGAL STANDARD THAT IS IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW FOR ANY USE OF
FORCE STILL APPLIES FOR THE USE
OF FORCE ON THE CANINES,
INCLUDING, AGAIN, THE
PROPORTIONAL FORCE REQUIREMENTS
THAT YOU CANNOT USE EXCESSIVE
FORCE AGAINST, YOU KNOW, A LOWER
LEVEL OF FORCE THAT IS
UNNECESSARY. I APPRECIATE THAT,
AND I KNOW THIS IS MORE
ANECDOTAL AND BUT I'VE HEARD
FROM, FRIENDS OF MINE WHO ARE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, A SCENARIO THAT
THEY WERE IN ONE TIME AND THEY
RELEASED A DOG IN A GARAGE, AND
THEY HEARD THE DOG YELP, AND
THEY KNEW THE DOG HAD BEEN
INJURED. AND THEY DECIDED RIGHT
THERE, THAT PERSON WASN'T COMING
OUT THEIR GARAGE ALIVE, AND THEY
KILLED THAT PERSON, AND THE DOG
WASN'T KILLED. BUT THE FACT THAT
YOU ATTACKED THE DOG, THEY
LOOKED AT AS ATTACK ON OFFICER,
WHICH HE IS AN OFFICER. THE DOG
IS AN OFFICER, BUT IT SHOULDN'T
REQUIRE SOMEONE TO LOSE THEIR
LIFE OVER INJURING A DOG. AND
THAT PERSON LOST THEIR LIFE. AND
I CAN MAKE A COMMENT AS TO THAT.
I ACTUALLY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION AT FIRST, BUT I THINK
EVERY CASE IS CASE BY CASE, AND
MOST INCIDENTS I HAVEN'T HEARD
OF ANY SUCH INCIDENT WHERE,
SOMEONE HAS KILLED ANOTHER
PERSON BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ATTACKED THE DOG, AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT IN THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS JUST A SET STATEWIDE
STANDARDS AS TO THE DEPLOYMENT
OF CANINES. DEVELOPED BY
DEPLOYING. GINA, I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR SERRANO,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BILL, I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES REGARDING
POLICE DOGS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. AND, YOU KNOW, THE USE
OF POLICE DOGS, FOR ANYBODY THAT
WORKS IN PUBLIC SAFETY OR HAS
BEEN IN PUBLIC SAFETY OVER THE
LAST 30 YEARS, CAN TELL YOU THAT
IT HAS EVOLVED. THE DOGS ARE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED, AND
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S NOT
MORE ROOM FOR MORE. AND I THINK
YOUR BILL ADDRESSES THAT. BY
CREATING, THE VARIOUS STANDARDS
AND, AND ALSO, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS, THAT
FIT TODAY'S WORLD, THE DOGS ARE
EXTREMELY USEFUL, I'VE, YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
ANECDOTAL STORIES, I DIDN'T
LISTEN TO SOMEBODY ELSE WHO
LISTENED TO SOMEBODY ELSE. I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO SEE, THE
RESULTS OF INCIDENTS THAT DON'T
HAVE DOGS VERSUS INCIDENTS WHERE
THE DOGS WERE UTILIZED. AND
WHILE, IT MAY HAVE, CREATED A,
YOU KNOW, THE USE OF THE DOG
ACTUALLY DEESCALATED A SITUATION
OR SITUATIONS THAT I'VE BEEN IN
AND, AND IT'S ALSO RESULTED IN
WAY LESS INJURIES FOR THE
PERSON, THAT WAS BEING TRYING TO
BE APPREHENDED. BUT HIDING AND,
AND THEY AND THEY DID HAVE
WEAPONS AND, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
ALL THESE DIFFERENT INCIDENTS
THAT HAPPEN. YEAH. YOU KNOW,
THINGS HAPPEN WHEN YOU'RE USING
ANY TOOL, WHEN YOU'RE DRIVING
YOUR, YOUR POLICE VEHICLE
INCIDENTS HAPPEN, IT IS A TOOL
AND IT IS A VALUABLE TOOL. DOGS
ABILITY TO, TO SMELL AND, AND
LOCATE SOMEBODY THAT'S HIDING
CAN PREVENT AN OFFICER FROM
BEING AMBUSHED AND SHOT. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY DEPLOY THEM IN
THOSE SITUATIONS, IT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT WE COULD USE MORE
TRAINING, AND I LIKE THAT YOUR
BILL FOCUSES ON THAT AS OPPOSED
TO, YOU KNOW, TALKING ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF DOGS WAY BACK 150
YEARS AGO AND, AND SAYING THAT
THAT'S A REASON FOR US NOT TO
USE THEM AT ALL, I THINK THEY'RE
VALUABLE, AS SAD AS IT IS, IT'S,
YOU KNOW, WHEN A DOG GETS SHOT,
WHICH WE HAVE HAD, IN FACT, WE
HAD ONE IN PARIS THAT GOT SHOT
AND KILLED, AND IT DIDN'T RESULT
IN, YOU KNOW, OTHER PEOPLE
GETTING KILLED, SOMETIMES IT
DOES. AND BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE
REMAIN A WEAPON OR REMAIN A
THREAT, AND THEY CONTINUE TO
THREATEN AT A LETHAL FORCE. AND
SO LETHAL FORCE IS USED TO TAKE
THEM DOWN, SO ALL OF THESE
ANECDOTAL STORIES, THEY'RE HERE,
THEY'RE, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE ON
BOTH SIDES, BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PURPOSES, WE HAVE TO FIND AN
AREA WHERE WE DO HAVE WE DO ARE
ENABLE ARE ABLE TO USE, THESE
POLICE DOGS, AND, AND WE, WE
NEED TO ENABLE THEM TO BE USED
SAFELY AS SAFELY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'RE
JUST LIKE ANYTHING ELSE, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S GOING TO BE BAD
INCIDENTS. AND, AND FOR THOSE
THAT ARE ACCIDENTALLY BITTEN,
THERE ARE CERTAINLY RECOURSES
THAT, COMPENSATE PEOPLE WHEN
THAT HAPPENS. AND, AND THAT'S,
THAT'S THE LEGAL PART OF IT, SO,
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT LIKE THEY
BITE SOMEBODY AND NOTHING
HAPPENS. AND AND, YOU KNOW, THEY
GO ON. BUT, YOU KNOW, I'D RATHER
I'VE TREATED BOTH. I'D RATHER
TREAT A DOG BITE THAN A BULLET
WOUND. AND, BECAUSE I CAN TELL
YOU, IN ALMOST 99% OF THE CASES,
THE BULLET WOUND IS A LOT MORE
LETHAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR THANK YOU, CONSIDERING
THAT WE HAVE TWO CANINE BILLS
AND BOTH AUTHORS IN THIS,
HEARING ROOM TODAY, I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS,
ONE, I WANT TO THANK YOU, AS THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, I DO KNOW
BOTH BILLS HAVE AMENDMENTS,
GIVEN TO THE AUTHORS, WHICH I
BELIEVE BOTH HAVE ACCEPTED. I
WANT TO SAY THAT FROM THE
OUTSET, THIS COMMITTEE DOES
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE, AND I AGREE
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE DO NEED MORE
PARAMETERS AND STANDARDS FOR THE
USE OF CANINES WHEN IT COMES TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THEIR DUTIES
ON THE JOB. I WILL SAY
PERSONALLY, I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
USING ANIMALS IN ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR, I'M NOT A BIG
FAN OF ZOOS OR AQUARIUMS OR
THINGS LIKE THAT. I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, PART OF, AN ANIMAL'S LIFE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I DO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT, AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CANINE ISSUES THAT
HAVE COME UP IN OUR CITY AND MY
PREVIOUS CITY, AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I'VE ALWAYS HAD
WAS THE FACT THAT OFTENTIMES THE
CANINE GOES AFTER THE WRONG
PERSON NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO IS
THE FACT THAT THE DAMAGE OF A
CANINE BITE DOES RESULT IN NERVE
DAMAGE, IT ALSO CREATES A LOT OF
FEAR FOR EXAMPLE, THERE ARE SOME
CULTURES THAT JUST GENUINELY DO
NOT LIKE ANIMALS. THEY DO NOT
NECESSARILY. THERE'S A FEAR OF
DOGS. THERE IS. YOU KNOW, SOME
PEOPLE BELIEVE IT'S AN OUTSIDE
ANIMAL, AND THEY ARE ABLE TO GET
INTO PLACES THAT OBVIOUSLY HUMAN
BEINGS CAN'T GET INTO AS
QUICKLY, SO FOR EXAMPLE, IF THE
EXAMPLE ABOUT A GARAGE AND SO
FORTH, IF THE ANIMAL WERE TO GO
INTO THE WRONG PERSON'S GARAGE,
IF THAT PERSON WAS AFRAID OF
DOGS, IF THAT PERSON FELT LIKE
THEY WERE DEFENDING THEMSELVES,
RIGHT, THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS
THERE AS TO WHAT IS APPROPRIATE.
WHEN SHOULD A CANINE BE RELEASED
AND WHAT IT SHOULD BE UTILIZED
FOR? OBVIOUSLY, WHEN WE GO INTO
AN AIRPORT AND WE SEE CANINES
THAT ARE EITHER SNIFFING FOR
BOMBS OR DRUGS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT MAKES
SENSE. THE HANDLER IS HOLDING
IT. BUT WE ALSO SEE A LOT OF
VIDEOS ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
CLEARLY SHOW THAT OFFICERS ARE
NOT FULLY TRAINED IN UTILIZING
AN ANIMAL. MORE SPECIFICALLY,
PULLING THE ANIMAL OFF AN
INDIVIDUAL AFTER THEY ARE BEING
ATTACKED. RIGHT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, IT IS AN ANIMAL, RIGHT,
NUMBER TWO, WE'VE ALSO SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF VIDEOS
THAT SHOW AN OFFICER POTENTIALLY
ABUSING A DOG AS WELL, EITHER
LEAVING IT IN A VEHICLE THAT HAS
OVERHEATED AND THAT ANIMAL HAS
DIED, OR EVEN JUST ABUSE BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW THEY BELIEVE THAT
THEY CAN GET THE DOG BACK IN
LINE. SO I THINK THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF CONCERN
AND RIGHTFULLY SO. AS WE ARE
DEALING WITH, AGAIN, A CREATURE
THAT CANNOT ALSO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES. SO WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ANIMALS AND THE WORK THAT
THEY DO AND SO FORTH. AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, ALSO PEOPLE'S
LIVES AS WELL AS THE ANIMAL'S
LIFE, SO I AGREE THAT IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT POLICE RECEIVE THE
PROPER TRAINING AND THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PUBLISH
DATA REGARDING THE USE OF
CANINES, I ALSO THINK THAT WE
SHOULD TRY TO FORCE WE SHOULD,
YOU KNOW, TAKE A LOOK AT A
SOLUTION ON SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPORTANT AS USE OF FORCE
STANDARD WITH LIMITED TIME TO
NEGOTIATE BEFORE OUR LAST
HEARING. THIS IS OUR LAST
HEARING, AND THE FACT THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE MULTIPLE SIDES THAT
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
HAVE NOT COME TO SOME SOLID
AGREEMENT AS TO WHAT DOES, THIS
LOOK LIKE MOVING FORWARD. AGAIN
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT STAKE, I
AM DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ANIMAL AS WELL, AND JUST A TOOL
THAT WE HAVE BEEN UTILIZING
WITHOUT ANY REAL STANDARDS
THERE. RIGHT. SO I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. I'M HOPING THAT BOTH
AUTHORS WORK WITH EACH OTHER, AS
WELL AS THE ADVOCACY GROUPS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS DISCUSSION,
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
REMOVING THAT STANDARD AND
DELAYING THE BILL'S OTHER
REQUIREMENTS REFLECT THE
COMMITTEE'S DESIRE THAT THE
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL CONTINUE NEGOTIATING NEXT
YEAR TO FIND A WORKABLE
COMPROMISE REGARDING THAT LEGAL
STANDARD. MY STAFF OBVIOUSLY,
CLEARLY WANTS TO HELP IN THIS
REGARD. AND AT THAT POINT, I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THIS IS A
CLARIFICATION OF REMOVING THE
STANDARD, DOESN'T MEAN THAT NO
USE OF FORCE STANDARD WILL APPLY
TO POLICE CANINES, SIMPLY THAT
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD
DEVELOPED IN CASE LAW WILL
CONTINUE TO GOVERN FOR THE TIME
BEING, WITH THAT, I WOULD ASK
YOU TO CLOSE AND WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MY CANINE BILL. I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE COMPANION BILL. WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER SINCE
THE. ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? YES, SENATOR
SARAH MOVES THE BILL. ITEM 21 AB
3241 PACHECO, MOTION IS DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB I. SATO. SATO. I BRADFORD.
SKINNER. WIENER THAT BILLS ON
CALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU, NEXT
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON WILL BE
PRESENTING FILE ITEM TWO, FILE
ITEM THREE, THE AB 1799. I
WANTED TO DO A PLACE ONE FIRST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR, AB 1799 WILL AMEND THE
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT
REPORTING ACT TO REMOVE THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT OF GENERAL
NEGLECT FOR MANDATED REPORTERS.
THE CURRENT DEFINITION OF
GENERAL NEGLECT IS OVERLY BROAD
AND INCORPORATES SITUATIONS THAT
ARE SCREENED OUT BY CHILD
PROTECTION AGENCY HOTLINE
WORKERS AT A HIGH RATE. THE
REMOVAL OF THE GENERAL NEGLECT
IS AN OFFICIAL RECOMMENDATION OF
THE CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH I AM A MEMBER,
AND, AS A MANDATED REPORTER AND
AS A FORMER MANDATED REPORTER,
AS A SOCIAL WORKER, REPORTER.
THIS ALSO MAKES SURE THAT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WILL
LOWER THE RATE OF SCREENED OUT
AND UNSUBSTANTIATED CALLS, TO
ENABLE RESOURCES TO BE
REDIRECTED TO SUBSTANTIATED
CASES OF ABUSE AND SEVERE
NEGLECT, AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY, REDUCE THE HARM AND
TRAUMA TO CHILDREN'S FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. AMENDING THIS
TO REMOVE GENERAL NEGLECT FROM
MANDATED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD NOT PROHIBIT MANDATED
REPORTERS FROM FROM REPORTING
GENERAL NEGLECT IF THEY
DETERMINE A CHILD IS A
SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF SUFFERING
SERIOUS PHYSICAL HARM OR
ILLNESS. FURTHER CALIFORNIA MUST
ENSURE THAT MANDATED REPORTERS
ARE ADEQUATELY TRAINED AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS AMENDMENT, THE CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL HAS A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS, OF WHICH THIS
IS ONLY ONE TO BEGIN. THIS
PROCESS OF CHANGING HOW MANDATED
REPORTING IS DONE IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE DON'T SEE THE HUGE
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST WHEN IT
COMES TO REPORTING BASED UPON,
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DATA AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE OVERLY TAX
SYSTEM IS ABLE TO FOCUS ON NOT
THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE MORE
SUBJECTIVE, AND CAN LEAD TO,
SOME REALLY BAD OUTCOMES THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW
DECADES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES? I DO NOT.
ALL RIGHT, SINCE WE HAVE NO LEAD
WITNESSES, WE'LL MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. LEAD
OPPOSITION. OKAY GOOD MORNING.
EILEEN KUBINSKI WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. I
WANT TO SAY I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THE AUTHOR JUST SAID
ON ON THIS BILL. WE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE MANDATED REPORTING TO
COMMUNITY SUPPORTING TASK FORCE
THAT MADE A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS, INCLUDING THE
ONE IN THIS BILL. TO WORK
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THE OVERALL
GOALS OF SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILY AND THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
REDUCING UNNECESSARY CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT, AS WELL AS
REDUCING DISPARITIES IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. OUR
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL AND WHY
WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED ON IT, IS THAT THIS
CHANGE ALONE TO THE GENERAL
NEGLECT REPORTING WILL NOT HAVE
THE INTENDED EFFECT OF REDUCING
CALLS TO CHILD WELFARE WITHOUT
TWO OTHER TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE BELIEVE THAT
NEED TO BE ENACTED CONCURRENTLY
AND ARE CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS
OF THIS THIS BILL. FIRST, THE
TRAINING OF MANDATED REPORTERS
MUST BE UPDATED AND IMPORTANTLY,
STANDARDIZED TO EXPLAIN THE NEW
POLICY AND RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER IT. IF ALL MANDATED
REPORTERS DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
AND AREN'T TRAINED CONSISTENTLY
ON HOW TO APPLY IT, THERE WILL
BE CONFUSION AND THE DEFAULT
WILL BE TO REPORT. AND SECOND,
THE LIABILITY STANDARDS FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS MUST BE
UPDATED IF MANDATED. REPORTERS
AND ATTORNEYS WHO ADVISE THEM
FEAR PROSECUTION OR CIVIL
LIABILITY. THIS LEADS TO FEAR
BASED DECISION MAKING THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAD TO OVER
REPORTING AS THE DEFAULT. SO WE
ASK THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
INCORPORATE THOSE TWO PROVISIONS
CONSISTENT WITH THE TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATION AND DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PARTICULAR CHANGE TO THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO JULY
1ST, 2026. WHILE THE TRAINING
AND LIABILITY CHANGES ARE
IMPLEMENTED, WE WANT TO SEE THE
CHANGES PROPOSED BY THIS BILL
SUCCEED, BUT WE DO NOT THINK IT
IS AS EFFECTIVELY ACCOMPLISHED
IN A PIECEMEAL FASHION. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
LEAD OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. CAN
WE JUST GET ME TWOS? WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL?
VANESSA CAJINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT AND
KIRK CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING NONE, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? SURE. I, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
STATEMENTS. I TOTALLY AGREE, WE
HAVE A WHOLE LOT MORE
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND IT'S MY
INTENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THOSE. JUST TO BE HONEST
, WE KNOW WE'RE IN A FISCAL
SITUATION. AND WHEN YOU START
TRYING TO DO TRAINING AND
CREATING CURRICULUM AND DOING
WEBSITES AND ALL THAT STUFF,
NUMBER ONE, WHO KNOWS WHEN THAT
WEBSITE IS GOING TO BE DONE, BUT
I THINK OVERALL, IT'S A MORE
APPROPRIATE TO DO THOSE OTHER
ITEMS THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
IN WHICH I INTEND TO DO NEXT
YEAR. BUT THE IDEA IS, IS THAT
WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE THIS. WE
KNOW THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME, AND WE'RE
GOING TO GET THE JOB DONE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? COURTESY MOTION? WE HAVE
A COURTESY MOTION BY SENATOR
SERRANO, ITEM THREE, AB 1799
JACKSON. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB Ã AYE
CIERTO. CIERTO NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD. SKINNER WIENER. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL, OUR NEXT BILL
WILL BE PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON, FILE NUMBER
FOUR, AB 2042, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AB 2042, AS
PART OF THE COMPANION
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS FIRST EVER
STATEWIDE STANDARDS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE USE OF POLICE K-9,
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND, I WOULD SAY VARIOUS,
RIGOROUS CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD REALLY DISCUSSING LINE
BY LINE, WHAT SHOULD BE IN THESE
BILLS TO MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE A VERY BALANCED
APPROACH, BUT TO ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD, IT IS JUST
SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR
CALIFORNIA NOT TO HAVE STATEWIDE
GUIDELINES FOR ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO,
FOLLOW. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR. DO YOU ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS? I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE LEAD
WITNESSES SEEING NONE. LEAD
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AGAIN. JUST TO RESTATE
MY NAME, IT'S CHRIS BURBANK, AND
I AM A RETIRED POLICE CHIEF, I
WON'T GO THROUGH MY RESUME AS TO
WHAT I'VE DONE BEFORE, BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THIS
MORNING TO DISCUSS A FEW THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP OR
MENTIONED. ONE IS THE FACT THAT
MOST POLICY ACROSS THE NATION
AND IN CALIFORNIA PROHIBITS THE
DEPLOYMENT OF A K-9 ON A
BARRICADED OR ARMED SUSPECT IS
GOING TO POTENTIALLY HARM THE
K-9. AND SO THIS DOES NOT
ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN OF A POLICE
OFFICER. IN FACT, IT'S NOT EVEN
TAKING THE PLACE BECAUSE POLICY
PROHIBITS THAT. SO WE ARE
RESERVING THE USE OF A K-9 NOT
FOR THE MOST SERIOUS AND
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS IN WHICH AN
OFFICER ENCOUNTERS, BUT THOSE
THAT ARE AT A LESSER STANDARD
AND AGAIN, WHEN THAT LESSER
STANDARD IS VAGUE OR UNCLEAR, WE
ARE LEAVING THAT TO THE DECISION
OF THE OFFICER. THE OTHER THING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT IS
ANIMALS, RIGHT? NO MATTER HOW
WELL TRAINED MAKE MISTAKES, THEY
HAVE A MIND OF THEIR OWN. THEY
ARE UNPREDICTABLE. AND WHILE I
WILL ABSOLUTELY AGREE, THESE ARE
AMAZINGLY TRAINED INDIVIDUAL
ANIMALS, THEY DO MAKE MISTAKES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
IS IMPORTANT IS AN APPREHENSION
DOG. THEIR REWARD. HOW THEY ARE
TRAINED IS TO BITE. SO BITING AN
INDIVIDUAL IS THE REWARD. BITING
A HUMAN BEING IS THE REWARD THAT
THE ANIMAL GETS FOR PERFORMING
ADEQUATELY. AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF POLICING.
AND AS WE LOOK AND WE START DOWN
THE ROAD, I BELIEVE THE SAME
AMENDMENTS THAT I SPOKE OF
SHOULD BE IN PLACE, ESPECIALLY
CROWD CONTROL. BUT AS WE LOOK
AND WE CONSIDER WHAT IS THE ROLE
OF POLICING IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY
AND WHY ARE WE EXPERIENCING WHAT
WE ARE EXPERIENCING? IT IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CRISIS OF
LEGITIMACY TAKING PLACE HERE.
LEGITIMACY IS NOT FOUND IN TRUST
US. WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT'S BEST
FOR YOU. LEGITIMACY IS FOUND IN
GOOD, SOLID BODIES SUCH AS THIS.
MAKING DECISIONS, OUTLINING
GUIDELINES, GOOD COMMON SENSE
GUIDELINES THAT MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL INVOLVED THAT ARE
REALISTICALLY. AND I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. MY NAME IS STILL
CHRISTIE LOPEZ. I'M FOR OVER A
DECADE I WAS DEPUTY CHIEF IN THE
U.S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AS I
SAID, AND I TEACH AT GEORGETOWN
LAW. WHILE MANY CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DO NOT USE
DOGS FOR FORCE AT ALL, IN SOME,
THE OPTION OF USING CANINES TO
INFLICT SERIOUS HARM ON PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COMMITTED ONLY MINOR
VIOLATIONS HAS BECOME
NORMALIZED. AND THIS IS IN PART
BECAUSE THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
CASE LAW THAT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
IN THIS AREA PROVIDES
INSUFFICIENT GUIDANCE.
LEGISLATION DOES PROVIDE THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY TO HIT THE
RESET BUTTON ON THIS NORMALIZED
ABUSE AND TO CREATE CONSISTENT,
DETAILED, AND STRICT LIMITATIONS
FOR WHEN CANINES MAY AND MAY NOT
BE DEPLOYED. UNFORTUNATELY, I'M
COMPELLED TO TESTIFY AGAINST AB
2042 BECAUSE THE STANDARD IT
WOULD SET AT THE STATE LEVEL IS
WORSE THAN THAT OF MANY POLICE
AGENCIES, INCLUDING AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. MOST
ANACHRONISTICALLY, THE BILL
PERMITS THE USE OF POLICE
CANINES FOR CROWD CONTROL. THIS
SHOULD BE COMPLETELY OFF THE
TABLE. THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS STATED
THAT CANINES ARE INAPPROPRIATE
FOR CROWD CONTROL, AND JUST LAST
YEAR, IN A LETTER TO THE
ASSEMBLY, PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE, CALIFORNIA POLICE
DEPARTMENTS EXPRESSED AGREEMENT
WITH A SECTION OF THE BILL THAT
SOUGHT TO PROHIBIT THE USE OF
CANINES FOR ANY FORM OF CROWD
CONTROL. THIS LEGISLATION SHOULD
DIRECTLY PROHIBIT THE USE THEIR
USE FOR CROWD CONTROL AND NOT
LEAVE IT TO POST TO DO WHATEVER
THEY SEE FIT. AB 2042 ALSO
ALLOWS CANINES TO BITE PEOPLE
BASED ON A THREAT OF RESISTANCE.
I AM UNAWARE OF ANY COURT
DECISION OR STATUTE PERMITTING
USE OF FORCE IN THIS MANNER.
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO, THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FOUND THAT THE PHOENIX POLICE
DEPARTMENT, WHICH LIKE
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE NINTH
CIRCUIT, HAD A PATTERN OF USING
UNREASONABLE FORCE, IN PART
BECAUSE OFFICERS WERE TRAINED TO
USE FORCE AGAINST SPECULATIVE
THREATS OF RESISTANCE. IN THE
SAME VEIN, THIS BILL'S OVERLY
PERMISSIVE LANGUAGE INVITES THE
USE OF EXCESSIVE FORCE. LASTLY,
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE ALLOWING
DEPLOYMENT WERE PROPORTIONAL TO
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENSE,
DOES NOT PROVIDE CLEAR GUIDANCE.
BASED UPON MY DECADES OF
REVIEWING CANINE PRACTICES, I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT TO PREVENT
THE ABUSE OF USE OF CANINES, IT
IS NECESSARY TO SET OUT CLEAR
RESTRICTIONS AT A MINIMUM,
POLICE CANINES SHOULD ONLY BE
DEPLOYED IF THE SUSPECT HAS
COMMITTED A VIOLENT FELONY. THE
USE IS PROPORTIONAL TO THE
IMMINENT THREAT AND LESSER FORCE
IS NOT FEASIBLE. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ME TWO'S.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. ALSO
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION.
GEORGE TH¤U ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION, THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT
AND ASIAN LAW ALLIANCE, WE HAVE
AN OPPOSING, AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHER SPEAKERS, SENATOR SERRANO.
ALL RIGHT, I DO WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE A PROHIBITION
ON THE USE OF CANINES FOR CROWD
CONTROL. SO THAT IS A CLEARLY
STATED POINT. SO, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES. OBVIOUSLY, WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH ISSUES LIKE THIS IS
A VERY COMPLICATED AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT, AGAIN, THE GOAL OF
THESE TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION
IS TO HAVE A BALANCED APPROACH
AND TO MAKE PROGRESS AND TO
MAKING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE DATA. YOU
KNOW, I REALLY THINK THAT, ALSO
THIS DOESN'T PROHIBIT POSTS FROM
CONTINUALLY LOOKING AND REVISING
THESE POLICIES INTO THE FUTURE.
IF WE SEE THERE'S SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
. BUT, IN TALKING WITH THOSE WHO
ARE SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING THIS
BILL, IT JUST SEEMED TO ME THAT
NO ONE REALLY HAD MUCH TRUST IN
ABOUT ANYTHING TO BE ABLE TO
COME TO A CONSENSUS, WHICH IS
WHY POST EXIST, AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS A REASONABLE START,
THERE'S NO SECRET HOW I FEEL.
AND HOW I'VE HAD A PREVIOUS BILL
THAT WAS DEFINITELY MORE
AGGRESSIVE, BUT SIMPLY DOING
NOTHING, I THINK IS OVERLY
PERMISSIVE AS WELL, AND SO YOU
KNOW, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THIS AND DO
THE BEST WE CAN FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN, I KNOW YOU WERE HERE WHEN
I MENTIONED MY OTHER COMMENTS,
SO I'M HOPING THAT WE HAVE
SOMETHING ON THE TABLE FOR NEXT
YEAR. I DO APPRECIATE YOUR WORK.
AND, THE COMMENTS STILL STAND
FOR ME, DO WE HAVE A COURTESY
MOTION? YES WE HAVE A COURTESY
MOTION, BY SENATOR SATO, CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL ITEM FOR AB
2042? JACKSON. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I, I CIERTO
CIERTO NOT VOTING. BRADFORD
SKINNER. WIENER. SO THAT BILL IS
ON CALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AB 544.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING. AND, SENATOR SATO, HERE
TO PRESENT AB 544, WHICH CREATE
A PILOT PROGRAM TO IMPROVE VOTER
PARTICIPATION IN CALIFORNIA,
SPECIFICALLY IN JAILS. PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN JAILS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA STILL LEGALLY
MAINTAIN THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
OVER THREE QUARTERS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN OUR
JAILS. ARE THERE PRETRIAL? THE
PROBLEM IS WE DON'T FACILITATE
ELECTIONS IN JAILS VERY WELL.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE VOTE BY MAIL
PROGRAMS TO FACILITATE VOTING IN
JAILS. HOWEVER, STATISTICS
INDICATE THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE A GROUP OVERWHELMINGLY
COMPRISED OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, STILL
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO VOTING AND ACCESSING VOTER
EDUCATION MATERIALS, WHICH
RESULTS IN LOWER OVERALL VOTER
TURNOUT. AB 544 WILL CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE
GRANTS TO THREE COUNTIES TO
IMPROVE VOTING ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN LOCAL
JAILS. IT WILL REQUIRE THE PILOT
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH A LOCATION
WHERE INCARCERATED PEOPLE CAN
VOTE, RETURN THEIR COMPLETED
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT, UPDATE
THEIR VOTER REGISTRATION, AND
CONDITIONALLY REGISTER TO VOTE.
THE PRIOR. THE PILOT PROGRAM
WILL BRING US CLOSER TO THE KIND
OF PARITY WE'RE SEEING IN OTHER
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY. JUST
RECENTLY, THE ENTIRE STATE OF
COLORADO TURNED EVERY SINGLE
JAIL INTO A POLLING PLACE. WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THIS KIND OF LOCAL
JAIL FACILITIES TURNING INTO
POLLING PLACES IN WASHINGTON,
DC, COOK COUNTY, WILK COUNTY IN
ILLINOIS, HARRIS COUNTY, TEXAS,
SO ON AND SO ON. THIS BILL TAKES
US CLOSER TO A DEMOCRACY THAT
INCLUDES EVERYBODY HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS TOM TRAN,
THE ARCHITECT OF THIS BILL FOR
MANY, MANY REASONS. FROM THE LÀ
FROM THE ELLA BAKER CENTER.
THANK YOU. YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
TOM TRAN, POLICY CONSULTANT WITH
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS NGUYEN DEMOCRACY. WORKS.
IT WORKS REALLY WELL. AN EXAMPLE
OF WHEN IT WORKED REALLY WELL
WAS ONE OF MY GOOD FRIENDS,
MARCUS, WHO I WAS INCARCERATED
WITH, AND HE SHARED WITH ME A
RARE OCCURRENCE THAT HAPPENED IN
COUNTY JAIL, A KIND CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER VOLUNTEERED DURING HIS
SHIFT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE POD THAT HE WAS
INCARCERATED IN KNEW THAT THEY
HAD THE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND THIS
OFFICER WAS ALSO WILLING TO
VOLUNTEER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAST A BALLOT. AND MARCUS AT
THIS TIME HAD NEVER VOTED
BEFORE. HE DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WAS
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE. HE DIDN'T KNOW
THE ISSUES THAT HE WAS GOING TO
BE VOTING ON. BUT WHEN HE SAW A
LINE BY LINE, THE ISSUES THAT
AFFECTED HIS MOTHER THAT
AFFECTED HIS CHILDREN, THAT
AFFECTED HIS FAMILY, HE FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER TRANSFORMED HIS
RELATIONSHIP TO THE COMMUNITY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER. HE FELT
LIKE HE HAD A STAKE IN THE
COMMUNITY, AND I SHARED THIS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I'LL SHARE IT
HERE. THE DAY THAT MARCUS VOTED
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN COUNTY
JAIL WAS THE DAY THAT MARCUS
LEFT THE GANG LIFE IN COUNTY
JAIL. THE DAY THAT HE VOTED AND
CASTED HIS FIRST BALLOT IN
COUNTY JAIL WAS THE DAY THAT HE
RECOMMITTED TO BEING A FATHER.
IN SPITE OF HIS INCARCERATION.
THE DAY HE CAST HIS BALLOT IN
COUNTY JAIL, DEMOCRACY WORKED SO
AB 544 IS ABOUT TAKING THIS RARE
INSTANCE OF TRANSFORMATION AND
DEMOCRACY AND REPLICATING THAT
EXPERIENCE, EXPANDING THAT
EXPERIENCE, AND NOT RELYING ON
ONE KIND OFFICER, BUT RELYING ON
US AS CALIFORNIANS TO SAY THAT
THE TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF
DEMOCRACY NEEDS TO BE ACCESSIBLE
TO EVERYONE, ESPECIALLY THE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES THAT
OVERREPRESENT OUR INCARCERATED
POPULATION. SO I IMPLORE YOU TO
PLEASE PASS AB 544. THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES SEEING NONE, CAN WE
GET LEAD OPPOSITION? THERE IS
NONE. THANK YOU, CAN WE GET ME
TWO'S? LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT ANTOINETTE
RATCLIFF WITH INITIATE JUSTICE.
PROUD CO-SPONSORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND I ALSO HAVE THE
PROXY OF GIVING THE SUPPORT OF
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS.
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIVAS. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT, YARI YANCY
WITH OAKLAND PRIVACY AND SUPPORT
, BARBARA CHÁVEZ WITH THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TATIANA LEWIS
WITH THE ELLA BAKER CENTER AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
EDITOR LITTLE, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. GEORGE
TH¤U, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M BERNIE SINGH
ROGERS, AN OUTSIDE ORGANIZER FOR
INITIATE JUSTICE AND INMATE
FAMILY COUNCIL OF SALINAS
VALLEY. I STRONGLY SUPPORT ROSE
ORTEZ LUCERO. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU, LAURA LARIOS, OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER, INITIATE JUSTICE,
STRONGLY SUPPORT MAKI SINGH
MASON CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. THANKS
DEBORAH. SAN CARLOS, CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. MOVING ON TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, SENATOR SERRANO HAS A
QUESTION. HEY, QUICK QUESTION.
SO WHEN THEY REGISTERED VOTER,
THEY VOTING IN THE CITY THAT
THEY'RE IN OR THE COUNTY THAT
THEY'RE IN, OR ARE THEY VOTING
IN THE COUNTY THEY CAME FROM, IN
OTHER WORDS, IF THEY IF THEY'RE
HOUSED IN, IN MURIETTA, BUT
THEY'RE KEPT AT A PRISON SYSTEM
UP HERE IN FOLSOM. YEAH. SO ARE
THEY REGISTERING FOR FOLSOM OR
MURIETTA? SO IT IS, IT IS IN THE
COUNTY. THIS IS ONLY FOR COUNTY
JAILS, WHICH ARE LOCATED IN THE
COUNTY WHERE YOU LIVE AND WHERE
YOU ARE FROM. I WOULD LOVE TO
RESTORE VOTING RIGHTS FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE IN PRISON THAT WOULD
HAVE THEIR VOTE COUNT COUNTED.
IN OTHER WORDS, LIKE AS AN
ABSENTEE VOTER TYPE SITUATION,
YOU ARE. YOU ARE VOTING FROM
WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS DOES. OR IT DOES NOT
DO. THAT IS WHAT THIS DOES, AND
THAT IS WHAT I WISH WE ALSO DID
AT STATE PRISONS. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A
CLOSE FROM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YES. THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE OTHER
HOUSE HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED HAVE
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE. WE JUST
DON'T DO IT. WELL, WE SHOULD DO
IT BETTER. DEMOCRACY THRIVES
WHEN IT INCLUDES EVERYBODY. I
WANT TO THANK MY WITNESS, TOM
TRAN, FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WITHOUT HIM, THIS BILL DOESN'T
EXIST. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALANIS THAT'S NOT BIPARTISAN.
OKAY, SO DO WE HAVE A COURTESY
MOTION? I'LL GIVE A COURTESY
MOTION. YOU HAVE A COURTESY
MOTION BY SENATOR SARTO. CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? VOTE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 544. O'BRIEN.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. SEYARTO NO. SATO.
NO. BRADFORD SCANNER. WIENER.
NO. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HERE.
SORRY. NOT YET. OKAY THANK YOU,
WE ARE ASKING FOR OTHER AUTHORS
TO SHOW UP. 2200. WE HAVE A LONG
LIST. WE HAD ONE EARLIER. I GOT
IT IN AUSTIN. DO YOU WANT.
TO?
HARD TIME ASSEMBLY. ALL RIGHT.
WE CAN LIFT THE CALL. LET'S
START FROM THE VERY TOP. SO,
SENATOR SKINNER CAN YOU READY?
READY. LET'S START WITH CONSENT.
AND CONSENT CALENDARS CURRENTLY
AT 3 TO 0. NANCY SKINNER.
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT. ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 1186. OH, NO, NO, WE
DIDN'T DO THAT ONE. SORRY. ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 544. BRYANT.
MOTION WAS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
1 TO 1. SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. ITEM THREE
AB 1799 JACKSON. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 1 TO 0. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. THAT BILL IS ON
CALL. ITEM FOUR AB 2042.
JACKSON. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 0. SKINNER
APOLOGIES. I HAVE TO ASK
QUESTIONS. OKAY THIS IS THE
JACKSON THAT TOOK AMENDMENTS,
OKAY. BECAUSE THAT WAS A BUNCH.
OH, YES. THEY DO PASS, AS
AMENDED TO OPPOSE. YEAH. SO
TAKING THE CROWD, WE TOOK THE
CROWD CONTROL OUT, WHICH IS, I
THINK, WHAT YOU WANTED. THEY
STILL BUT THERE WASN'T OUR
COMMITTEE THERE CONJOINED. YES
YEAH. THEY BOTH TOOK AMENDMENTS.
IT IS COMPLEMENTARY TO EACH
OTHER AND NOTHING SIGNIFICANT IN
THE SENSE THAT NEXT YEAR THEY
HAVE TO COME BACK TO THE TABLE.
YOU MIGHT NEED.
TO.
COME BACK. YEAH. WE'RE JUST
GOING TO SKIP THAT ONE. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S LET'S KEEP GOING.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 2064. JONES. SAWYER. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. SKINNER.
SKINNER. I BACK TO THE LAST ONE.
SORRY. ITEM NUMBER 21 AB 3241.
PACHECO. MOTION WAS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WE'RE
COMING BACK TO THAT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NOW WE HAVE
FILE ITEM 18 AB 2959 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA, SHE WILL PRESENT
I WILL HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PRESENTING THEIR
OWN BILLS AND SERVING ON OTHER
COMMITTEES, MYSELF INCLUDED. I
WILL BE STEPPING OUT IN A LITTLE
BIT AS WELL. AND SENATOR SAWYER
WILL TAKE OVER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING. MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS FOR THE UP. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2959 BEFORE YOU ALL TODAY.
THIS BILL DIRECTLY AFFECTS THE
LIVES OF COUNTLESS FAMILIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. CURRENTLY,
FAMILIES VISITING THEIR LOVED
ONES IN CDCR FACILITIES ARE
CONFRONTED WITH EXTRAORDINARILY
HIGH FOOD PRICES. ADDITIONALLY,
VISITORS ARE LIMITED IN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY CAN
BRING INTO FACILITIES. FAMILIES
CAN ONLY BRING UP TO $70 PER
ADULT OR $40 PER CHILD TO BUY
SNACKS AND FOOD ITEMS. THE COST
OF FOOD IN THESE FACILITIES IS
UNREGULATED, WHICH RESULTS IN
PRICES THAT ARE SOMETIMES 2 OR 3
TIMES HIGHER THAN WHAT THEY
WOULD BE IN A LOCAL STORE. AB
2959 AIMS TO RECTIFY THIS, AND
REQUIRES THAT FOOD PRICES IN
PRISON VENDING MACHINES ALIGN
WITH THE AVERAGE MARKET RETAIL
PRICE IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE PRISONS ARE LOCATED. AB 2959
IS A STEP TOWARDS FAIRNESS,
AFFORDABILITY AND DIGNITY.
WITNESS. TODAY I HAVE TESTIFYING
WITH ME LAWRENCE COX WITH THE
REGIONAL ADVOCACY AND ORGANIZING
ASSOCIATE FOR LEGAL SERVICES. WE
ALSO HAVE JENNIFER PENROSE WITH
THE POWER AND UNITY FELLOWSHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BOTH
SPEAKERS THAT ARE PRIMARY
WITNESSES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. WELCOME. HOW ARE YOU GUYS
DOING? MY NAME IS LAWRENCE, I AM
SYSTEM IMPACTED, I SPENT 17
YEARS BEHIND THE WALLS, ENDURE
INCARCERATION BECAUSE OF MY OWN
ACTIONS, I'D ALSO LIKE TO UPLIFT
THAT. REHABILITATION IS KEY. AND
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEES HAVE
ALWAYS AGREED THAT ONE OF THE
BEST CONDUITS TO HELPING
DECREASE RECIDIVISM IS IN
INCLUDING AND UPLIFTING VISITING
AND THAT REQUIRES REMOVING
BARRIERS TO VISITING. ALSO, IF
WE WANT TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
VISITING, WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THESE VISITING ROOMS. OUR
VISITING ROOMS ARE OUR CONDUITS
TO INCREASING THESE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
HAVE MOMENTS IN THE SHARE TIME
WITH THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR
LOVED, THEIR LOVED ONES. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DO THAT WHEN PRICES
ARE SOMETIMES MARKED UP ANYWHERE
FROM TWO TO 300 TO 400,
SOMETIMES EVEN 500. AND WE ALSO
HAVE TO REALIZE THAT SOME OF
THESE FAMILIES COME FROM LOWER
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS, AND
ALREADY SINGLE HOMES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE IT ON THE
STREET ALREADY AS WELL. SO WITH
THIS BILL ACTUALLY SEEKS TO DO,
IS KIND OF EASE THE BURDEN AND
CAP THE PRICE THAT VENDORS ARE
ALLOWED TO CHARGE ON THE FOOD
THAT ARE IN THE VENDING
MACHINES. I THINK THIS WOULD GO
GREAT FOR HELPING INCREASE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO COME TRAVEL AND SEE
THEIR LOVED ONES MORE OFTEN THAN
THEY PROBABLY ALREADY ARE. AND I
WILL. JENNIFER, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, MA'AM.
OKAY. THANK YOU. HELLO MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME. I'M
JENNIFER PENROSE WITH POWER AND
UNITY FELLOWSHIP AND I AM SYSTEM
IMPACTED, TODAY I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY ON THE STRUGGLES I
PERSONALLY FACE IN THE VISITING
ROOM WITH THE VENDING MACHINE
AND QUALITY AND PRICES AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB 2959, IF YOU
WERE OUT, FOR A WEEKEND WITH
YOUR LOVED ONES AT THE FARMER
MARKET AND. SORRY, YOU CAUGHT A
WHIFF OF SOMETHING THAT SMELLED
GOOD. IT'S A VENDOR. THEY'RE
SELLING STREET TACOS, AND YOU
FIND OUT THAT THE TACOS $10, YOU
ARE GOING TO PROBABLY PASS ON
THAT AND GO HOME AND MAKE SOME
FOOD OR GO SOMEWHERE ELSE WITH
BETTER QUALITY PRICES, WE DON'T
GET THAT OPPORTUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY, OUR FAMILIES ARE
OFFERED GAS STATION QUALITY
BURGERS, BURRITOS, PIZZAS AND
CHIPS FOR THE WEEKEND. A WEEKEND
IN AND OUT ONLY. THE PRICES ARE
OVER DOUBLE THAN THAT AT THE GAS
STATION. WE AREN'T ALLOWED TO
BRING FOOD INTO THE PRISON AND
WE'RE NOT OFFERED ANY OTHER
OPTIONS. THESE VENDORS ARE
MONOPOLIZING OFF OF A
DEMOGRAPHIC OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO GET BY,
AND THE MOTHER OF TWO SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN. I AM A FULL TIME
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I WORK LESS
THAN PART TIME. I'M FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERYTHING IN
OUR FAMILY FROM RENT, BILLS,
SPORTS, FIELD TRIPS, NECESSITIES
, QUARTERLY PACKAGES, AND
VISITING, THIS WEEKEND I WILL
HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE TO EITHER
BORROW FROM MY RENT MONEY OR
SUBMIT MY RENT MONEY BECAUSE
TEMPERATURES WILL REACH OVER 105
DEGREES IN VACAVILLE, I WANT TO
GO TAKE MY HUSBAND OUT OF THE
HOT CEMENT BUILDING THAT WILL
PROBABLY REACH OVER 120 DEGREES,
AND GIVE HIM SOME RELIEF FROM
THE HEAT. AND THAT WILL COST MY
FAMILY $320 THIS WEEKEND. AND,
FOR ME, ONLY BEING 20 MINUTES
DOWN THE STREET, THAT'S STILL A
LOT. BUT THERE ARE FAMILIES THAT
COME FROM FAR THAT HAVE TO PAY
ALMOST A WHOLE MONTH'S WORTH OF
RENT JUST FOR ONE WEEKEND TO
SPEND WITH THEIR FAMILY. THANK
YOU MA'AM. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? IF WE
DON'T, WE'LL TAKE THE METOOS.
ANYBODY WHO IS IN FAVOR OR
OPPOSING THE BILL, PLEASE COME
UP, STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
OPPOSITION OR APPROVAL. AND, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT.
THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT GEORGE BRANDT
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
KATRINA REES, ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
BARBARA CHÁVEZ WITH THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS ALL OF US ARE
NONE OAKLAND IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, TATIANA LEWIS FROM THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT, AS WELL AS LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. THANK YOU AND LITTLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
BERNIE SINGH ROGERS, OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND INMATE FAMILY COUNSEL WITH
SALINAS VALLEY. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT LARA LARIOS, OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ROSA
ORTEZ LUCERO. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ALSO. OKAY I THOUGHT YOU WERE
COMING UP TO SAY THAT YOU
SUPPORT. SO I WAS WAITING, ALL
RIGHT, SO WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DÍAS. ANY QUESTIONS? A
MOTION. SENATOR SKINNER, I THINK
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE THAT CAN
MAKE A MOTION UP HERE. SORRY I
MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL? ROLL ITEM 18, AB
2959. ORTEGA. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
SATO. NO. SATO NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER I WIENER CALL. BILLS ON
CALL, I WILL. I GOT IT SO THAT
BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL. THANK
YOU, MISS SANCHEZ. YOU'RE BACK.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU NEXT.
COME ON UP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND GIVING YOU THE
EXTRA STEPS WE GAVE YOU EXTRA
STEPS TODAY. IT'S ONE OF THOSE
WEEKS. YES. ALL GOOD. ALL RIGHT.
GREAT. THIS IS AB 1978, I
BELIEVE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS. I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS
BILL. STREET RACING IS AN
EPIDEMIC THAT HAS LED TO THE
PREVENTABLE DEATHS OF COUNTLESS
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN A SHARP RISE
IN ILLEGAL STREET RACING AS
STREET RACERS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE HIGHWAYS, PARKING LOTS AND
ROADS THROUGH FORCIBLY BLOCKING
CARS FROM USING THE. THESE
ROADWAYS. ILLEGAL STREET RACING
IS NOT ONLY DANGEROUS, BUT IT
OFTEN HAS FATAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
PARTICIPANTS, PEDESTRIANS,
COMMUTERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALIKE. ON JANUARY 1ST, 2024, A
23 YEAR OLD WOMAN WAS KILLED BY
A DRIVER WHO LOST CONTROL OF THE
VEHICLE WHILE PARTICIPATING IN A
SIDESHOW IN STOCKTON,
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS JUST ONE OF
THE COUNTLESS CASES OF SENSELESS
AND PREVENTABLE DEATHS FROM
STREET RACING ACCIDENTS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFTEN STRUGGLE TO EFFECTIVELY
CURB SIDE SHOWS AND EXHIBITIONS
OF SPEED, AS OFTENTIMES THESE
SIDESHOWS ARE JUST CONTINUE IN A
DIFFERENT INTERSECTION WITH THE
SAME PARTICIPANTS. AFTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT BROKE UP, THE
ORIGINAL EVENT, AB 1978, WILL
ALLOW PEACE OFFICERS TO SEIZE A
VEHICLE THAT BLOCKS A ROAD TO
FACILITATE STREET RACES WITHOUT
NEEDING TO TAKE THE OWNER OF THE
VEHICLE INTO CUSTODY. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT SPEED EXHIBITIONS
WILL NOT CONTINUE IN A DIFFERENT
LOCATION. ONCE A STREET RACE HAS
BEEN DISPERSED BY PEACE OFFICERS
AND WILL KEEP ROADS, PEDESTRIANS
AND OTHER DRIVERS SAFE. THIS
BILL IS SUPPOSED IS SUPPORTED BY
MANY GROUPS AIMING TO PROTECT
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS SUCH AS
STREET RACING KILLS THE CONNOR
LYNCH FOUNDATION AND SOCAL
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS.
TESTIFYING WITH ME TODAY IS
LIEUTENANT BRANDON EPP WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU. AS THE
LEAD, OUR LEAD WITNESS FOR THE
BILL. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
BRANDON, UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS VERY TIMELY
BECAUSE OVER THE PAST THREE DAYS
IN LOS ANGELES, WE SAW TWO MAJOR
STREET TAKEOVER EVENTS. EACH
EVENT SAW MORE THAN 50 CARS
BLOCK OFF TWO DIFFERENT
INTERSECTIONS ON TWO DIFFERENT
DAYS. IN LOS ANGELES, ONE OF THE
EVENTS CAUSED TWO VEHICLES TO BE
BURNED DOWN, AND THE OTHER EVENT
THAT WHICH HAPPENED YESTERDAY
MORNING AT 3 A.M, SAW AN MTA BUS
BEING TAKEN OVER WITH
PASSENGERS, AND IT WAS
VANDALIZED COMPLETELY. NÓ.
LUCKILY, NO PASSENGERS WERE WERE
ASSAULTED OR BATTERED. BUT IT
WAS, I'M SURE AS A BUS RIDER
WOULD BE QUITE TRAUMATIZING TO
SEE 50 VEHICLES SURROUND YOUR
BUS. BEGIN A SIDESHOW AND THEN
START VANDALIZING VANDALIZING
THE BUS THAT YOU'RE IN. SO IT'S
VERY TIMELY, WE NEED ANY
DETERRENT WE CAN GET OUT THERE.
THESE ARE POPPING UP EVERY
WEEKEND. AND EACH ONE OF THESE
SHOWS, NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE THE
PERFORMERS IN THE SHOW, BUT YOU
DO HAVE THESE AIDERS AND
ABETTORS THAT ARE BLOCKING THE
STREETS, DETERRING EGRESS AND
INGRESS, PRIMARILY PREVENTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM, FROM
ENTERING SO WE COULD TAKE
ACTION. I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT,
BY TOWING THESE VEHICLES, I
THINK IT WOULD FALL UNDER THE
COMMUNITY CARETAKING, DOCTRINE.
BECAUSE IF WE SIGHT THIS PERSON
AND GIVE THEIR CAR BACK, THEY'RE
NOT JUST GOING TO GO HOME AND
CALL IT QUITS, THEY'RE MOST
LIKELY GOING TO GO OUT LATER
THAT DAY AND, AND COMMIT THE
SAME, SAME CRIME. AND IF NOT
THAT DAY, THEY'RE GOING TO GO
OUT THE NEXT DAY. AND THE
FOLLOWING WEEKEND. SO I THINK WE
WOULD BE PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY AND CARETAKING THE
COMMUNITY BY MAKING SURE THIS
CAR DOESN'T OR ISN'T AVAILABLE
OVER THE COMING DAYS OR WEEKS.
SO WITH THAT, I, SUPPORT THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF L.A. COUNTY
SHERIFF. AND WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY. ANY
OTHER LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
OKAY. LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. COMING UP. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU. HI.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ERIC HENDERSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO 19 AB 1978 BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO. LAWYERS COMMITTEE IS
ONE OF THE OLDEST CIVIL RIGHTS
INSTITUTIONS ON THE WEST COAST
AND WORKS TO DISMANTLE SYSTEMS
OF OPPRESSION, OPPRESSION, AND
RACISM AND BUILD AN EQUITABLE
AND JUST SOCIETY. AB 1978
PRESENTS SERIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS WHICH ARE NOTED IN
DETAIL IN THIS COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL. UNDER THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT, A WARRANT IS
REQUIRED TO TOW A VEHICLE UNLESS
THE VEHICLE FALLS UNDER A
LIMITED NUMBER OF EXCEPTIONS TO
THE WARRANT REQUIREMENT. THE
VEHICLES THAT WOULD BE TOWED
UNDER AB 1978 ARE NOT ACCEPTED
FROM THE WARRANT REQUIREMENT.
COURTS HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT
EVEN IF CITIES ARE FOLLOWING A
STATE LAW, IF THE UNDERLYING TOW
VIOLATES THE CONSTITUTION,
CITIES CAN BE HELD LIABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY EXPOSE CITIES TO
RESOURCE INTENSIVE LITIGATION
AND COSTLY LIABILITY. WHILE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO VIOLATE
THEIR CITIZEN'S MOST FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS. FURTHERMORE, AB 1978
CREATES THE POTENTIAL FOR MISUSE
. AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN, AB 1978
DOES NOT REQUIRE INDIVIDUALS TO
HAVE USED THEIR VEHICLE IN A
SIDESHOW OR STREET RACE FOR IT
TO BE IMPOUNDED, ALLOWING
OFFICERS TO DISCRETION TO
IMPOUND THE VEHICLES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATING IN THE SIDESHOW OR
STREET RACE RAISES THE RISK OF
DISCRIMINATORY OR INEQUITABLE
POLICING. LOSING A VEHICLE TO AN
IMPOUND IS EXTREMELY HARMFUL TO
LOW INCOME AND WORKING PEOPLE,
AND CAN HAVE A CASCADE OF
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES. THERE ARE
BETTER APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING
STREET TAKEOVERS THAT DO NOT
INFRINGE UPON AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OR REQUIRE
THE IMPOUND OF VEHICLES. FOR
THESE REASONS, LAWYERS COMMITTEE
REQUESTED NO VOTE ON AB 1978.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE YOU
ALSO A LEAD WITNESS? AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. HI.
GOOD MORNING. I'M YADI WITH
OAKLAND PRIVACY, A COALITION
THAT FOCUSES ON REGULATION AND
GUARDRAILS IN THE INTEREST OF
PRIVACY PROTECTION, CIVIL RIGHTS
AND COMMUNITY CONSENT. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
1978. IN OUR VIEW, THE BILL
VIOLATES THE FOURTH AMENDMENT.
WARRANTLESS IMPOUNDMENT OF
VEHICLES ARE GENERALLY
PROHIBITED BY THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT, WITH NARROW
EXEMPTIONS RELATED TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF ROADS. AB 1978
TERMINOLOGY OF AIDING AND
ABETTING A SPEED CONTEST IS FAR
BROADER THAN THAT WHICH IS
ALLOWED. IN ADDITION, BY
AUTHORIZING IMPOUNDMENTS EVEN
WHEN THE DRIVER IS NOT TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY. AB 1978 ALLOWS
IMPOUNDMENTS FOR THAT FALL FAR
SHORT OF A PROBABLE CAUSE
STANDARD. SO FOR THAT, WE ASK
THAT YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. AT THIS
TIME, WE WILL TAKE, METOOS.
ANYBODY WHO IS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSING THE BILL JUST COME UP,
STATE YOUR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
AND THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT. MR. CHAIR MEMBERS
PAUL YODER ON BEHALF OF THE
SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT MARKET
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS VICTORIA RODRIGUEZ WITH
NIELSEN MERKSAMER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LA AND SUPPORT
MORNING. SHEILA CHONG WITH
HERNANDEZ STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION,
GEORGE TH¤U, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN RESPECT OF
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KELLI O'BRIEN WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. OKAY LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE OUT OF SPEAKERS. SO AT
THIS TIME, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS FOR QUESTIONS OR
MOTION. IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A
MOTION. YOU WANT TO MAKE A
COURTESY MOTION. I DID LIKE FIVE
OF THEM. WANT ME TO TAKE THE
GAVEL? NO BECAUSE THEN YOU WON'T
GIVE IT BACK. YEAH. GIVE HER THE
GAVEL FOR A MINUTE. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL? I'LL MAKE A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. ÁP 1978 HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR SATO. AND
I HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS. IF
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE DONE, I WILL
JUST COMMENT THAT I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT. THE DIFFICULTY
OF HAVING STREETS BLOCKED,
HOWEVER, THE, THE IMPACT OF
IMPOUNDING A VEHICLE IS QUITE
SEVERE, AND I AM NOT SURE THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY ANSWER TO THIS
PROBLEM. SO, I'LL TURN IT OVER
NOW TO SENATOR SATO FOR HIS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
OBVIOUSLY, I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY, THE IMPACT OF
HAVING YOUR VEHICLE IMPOUNDED IS
VERY SEVERE, AND I FEEL BAD FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THAT CHOICE FOR
THEMSELVES, THE POLICE OFFICERS
ARE NOT MAKING THAT CHOICE FOR
ANYBODY. WE ARE NOT MAKING THAT
CHOICE FOR ANYBODY. THE PERSONS
THAT ARE MAKING THE CHOICE TO
HAVE THEIR CAR IMPOUNDED ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO DECIDE TO, IGNORE,
LAW AND DECENT SOCIETY AND GO
OUT AND HAVE STREET RACES THAT
DO RESULT IN DEATHS OF INNOCENT
PEOPLE AND, AND ALSO DISTURBING,
DISTURBING THE PEACE, THE LITTLE
THE LITTLE DONUTS AND THINGS
THAT THE INTERSECTIONS THAT
HAPPEN AT ALL TIMES OF THE
NIGHT, THE POLICE NEED SOMETHING
BETTER THAN JUST A SLAP ON THE
HAND FOR THOSE THAT ARE ENGAGING
IN THIS. AND IT'S BECOMING A
BIGGER AND BIGGER PROBLEM. SO I
THINK THE BEST SOLUTION FOR
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT THEIR CAR
TO BE IMPOUNDED OR SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT IS TO NOT
ENGAGE IN THE ACTIVITY. THAT'S
THAT'S, I THINK, PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY HERE WOULD ENABLE
SOMEBODY TO ESCAPE ANY OF THE
LAWS THAT ARE MEANT FOR PEOPLE
WHO DO BREAK LAWS. AND I THINK A
LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T EVEN THINK
ABOUT THAT ANYMORE, WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO THINK OF THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR PEOPLE WHO
INSIST ON BREAKING LAWS. AND SO,
WITH THAT, OH, THAT'S RIGHT. I'M
NOT RUNNING THIS THIS SHOW.
YOU'RE RUNNING THIS SHOW BACK TO
YOU. YES, WE HAVE A MOTION,
PLEASE ROLL CALL ON. SORRY,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. OH,
APOLOGIES. APOLOGIES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANCHEZ, PLEASE.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. AB
1978 IS A REASONABLE MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A PRACTICAL
TOOL FOR DETERRING SIDESHOWS
ACROSS THE STATE THROUGH
ALLOWING POLICE OFFICERS TO
IMPOUND VEHICLES WITHOUT TAKING
A PERSON INTO CUSTODY. THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO HAMSTRING ADDITIONAL
SPEED EXHIBITIONS AND SAVE
COUNTLESS LIVES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL NOW HAVE OUR ROLL
CALL ON THAT VOTE. ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB 1978. SANCHEZ. MOTION IS
Dð PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB SEYARTO HI. SATO I
BRADFORD. SKINNER. WIENER ALL
RIGHT. THAT, BILL IS GOING TO
STAY ON CALL. IT HAS ONE VOTE
NOW, BUT WE WILL HAVE OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS WHEN THEY RETURN. WE'LL
OPEN THE ROLL AGAIN. AND THERE
YOU GO. THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE WHEN WE'RE ESPECIALLY AT
THIS TIME OF YEAR, WE'RE DOING
FIRST COME, FIRST SERVE. AND
APPARENTLY I HAVE BAINES,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES. FIRST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BAUER-KAHAN.
SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BERMAN
THIRD AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BONTA
FOURTH. DOES THAT SOUND RIGHT TO
YOU GUYS? OKAY, BECAUSE I DIDN'T
I DIDN'T OBSERVE WHO CAME IN
FIRST. SO IT'S ON YOUR HONOR.
OKAY MISS BAINES, WHY DON'T YOU
COME ON UP? SORRY. THIS WILL BE
THIS WILL BE AB 3029. THANK YOU.
CHAIR EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE
COMMITTEE PASSED SB 1502 TO
SCHEDULE XYLAZINE, WHICH IS ALSO
KNOWN AS KNOWN AS TRANQ. AB 3029
WOULD ALSO SIMILARLY PROPOSE A
SCHEDULE XYLAZINE CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL SCHEDULING
PROPOSALS, AB 3029 WOULD ALSO
MAKE TEST STRIPS AVAILABLE TO
DETERMINE IF A SUBSTANCE HAS
BEEN ADULTERATED WITH XYLAZINE
AND EMPOWER CDFW TO MAKE TEST
STRIPS AVAILABLE. AS WE SEE
OTHER ADULTERANTS EMERGE.
IMPORTANTLY, BOTH 1502 AND 3029
PROTECT LEGITIMATE VETERINARY
USES OF XYLAZINE, WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL, ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
IN LARGE ANIMAL MEDICINE AS
THERE ARE FEW, IF ANY, OTHER
ALTERNATIVE MEDICATIONS
AVAILABLE. AB 3029 IS SUPPORTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
VETERINARIANS, AND IS ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
CALL LATE LAST YEAR TO MAKE
XYLAZINE A SCHEDULE DRUG, WITH
ME SUPPORT TODAY. OH, GREAT. YOU
MADE IT. HI, DOCTOR, IS DIRECTOR
OF REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICINE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. DOCTOR
GRANT MILLER. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
BAINES. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR HEARING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY. AND ALSO,
THANK YOU TO DOCTOR BAINES FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE, THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 3029
BECAUSE IT MAKES AGGRESSIVE
MOVES TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM
XYLAZINE DIVERSION AND ABUSE,
WHILE BALANCING THE NEED FOR
VETERINARIANS TO MAINTAIN ACCESS
TO THIS IMPORTANT DRUG FOR
PRIMARILY USE IN LIVESTOCK,
HORSES AND WILDLIFE SPECIES. I
ACTUALLY AM A HORSE
VETERINARIAN, SO I USE XYLAZINE
ON A ROUTINE BASIS. IT'S
COMMONLY USED FOR SEDATION AND
PAIN CONTROL IN VERY LARGE
ANIMALS, AND IT ENABLES US TO
PERFORM PROCEDURES ON THEM
SAFELY THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
REALLY RESULT IN A DANGER TO
BOTH THEM AND US, IT'S EASILY
RANKED AMONG ONE OF THE TEN MOST
IMPORTANT DRUGS THAT WE USE ON
ON LIVESTOCK AND HORSES. AND I
MYSELF WILL USE IT IN ABOUT 75%
OF MY ROUTINE APPOINTMENTS. IT
PROVIDES EXCELLENT, QUICK AND
PREDICTABLE SEDATION AND PAIN
CONTROL IN JUST ABOUT 45 TO 60S,
AND I WILL COMMONLY USE IT IN
EMERGENCIES. I USE IT TO CALM
THESE HORSES DOWN SO THAT I CAN
THEN, YOU KNOW, SEW UP A WOUND
THAT THEY HAVE. I DO DENTAL WORK
WITH THEM, USING THIS DRUG, THE
RISK TO ME IF I DID NOT HAVE
THIS DRUG AVAILABLE WOULD BE
SOMETHING I DON'T WANT TO
IMAGINE. SO I'M HAPPY TO GIVE
YOU ANY OTHER EXAMPLES, IF YOU'D
LIKE, ABOUT HOW WE USE IT IN
PRACTICE, BUT SUFFICE IT TO SAY,
WE ARE SKILLED IN HANDLING,
CONTROLLED DRUGS. THIS DRUG HAS
NO PURPOSE OTHER THAN TO BE USED
IN VETERINARY MEDICINE. IT HAS
NO PLACE ANYWHERE ELSE OTHER
THAN FOR USE IN IN IN LIVESTOCK.
SO, BRINGING IT BACK AB 3029
WILL ALIGN CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
FEDERAL LEGISLATION THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN MOTION TO MAKE
XYLAZINE A SCHEDULE II
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ON THE
FEDERAL DEA LIST, BUT IT DOES.
SO AB 3029 SKILLFULLY DOES SO BY
INCORPORATING LANGUAGE THAT
ENSURES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THIS DRUG TO KEEP OUR
PATIENTS SAFE AND US SAFE WHILE
KEEPING IT OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T NEED TO HAVE
IT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE AND I'M HAPPY
TO ASK OR ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL? IF NOT, WE'LL TAKE LEAD
OPPOSITION. IF THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION, WE'LL TAKE THE
METOOS FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. COMING UP, STATE
YOUR NAME. THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT, AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL,
GEORGE FRAMPTON, ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NOT JUST OPPOSITION, BUT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
APPRECIATE THAT. ANYONE ELSE?
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DÍAS FOR ANY QUESTIONS. A
MOTION.
A MOTION COURTESY MOTION. I WILL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? SURE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS THE FIRST AND ONLY ADDICTION
SPECIALIST IN THE LEGISLATURE,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A VERY, VERY LONG
TIME, WHEN IT COMES TO WHEN IT
COMES TO XYLAZINE SPECIFICALLY,
THIS TIME LAST YEAR, I WARNED
CALIFORNIA OF THE EMERGENCE OF
XYLAZINE THAT WAS HITTING
PENNSYLVANIA AND OTHER AREAS. I
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH THE
PENNSYLVANIA PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO STRENGTHEN THE
PROTOCOLS THAT WERE NEEDED TO BE
PLACED RIGHT AWAY. SCREENING AND
TESTING IS REALLY IMPORTANT. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES RIGHT NOW
ON CONTROLLING TRANQ IS THE FACT
THAT WE'RE NOT SCREENING FOR IT.
WE REALLY HAVE NO IDEA HOW
PREVALENT IT IS IN OUR SOCIETY
RIGHT NOW, WE LEARN ABOUT
FENTANYL, WHICH IS OPIOID BASED.
XYLAZINE IS NOT OPIOID BASED. SO
WE NEED TO EFFECTIVELY START
WORKING ON ANTIDOTES TO HELP IN
OVERDOSE CASES WHERE NARCAN
CANNOT BE USED TO REVERSE
OVERDOSES OF TRANQ, THIS IS AN
ONGOING DRUG CRISIS THAT AMERICA
FACES. I FEAR EVERY YEAR AND
YEAR THERE'S GOING TO BE A NEW
EMERGING DRUG. WE REALLY NEED TO
WORK HARD ON CONTROLLING OUR
EMERGING DRUGS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE KEEPING UP WITH
TESTING. THIS BILL ALLOWS CDPH
TO BE ABLE TO START TESTING AND
GET A HEADS UP ON THE NEW
EMERGING DRUGS AND RESEARCH THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE PROPER ANTIDOTES
AND PROPER SCREENING SO WE KNOW
HOW TO EFFECTIVELY COMBAT DRUGS,
LIKE I SAID, AS A PHYSICIAN AND
THE PERSONAL ADDICTION
SPECIALIST AND LEGISLATURE, THIS
IS SOMETHING I'VE WORKED ON FOR
A VERY LONG TIME, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING THIS.
AND OTHER PROTOCOLS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. GREAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I DIDN'T CHECK TO
SEE YOU WERE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. YES, YES. SO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING ACCEPTED.
AND I ALSO DIDN'T GET TO SAY I
REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
USING YOUR EXPERTISE TO TACKLE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES, BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES WE DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
TACKLE. AND YOU DO. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL. WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD AND CALL ROLL ITEM 19
AB 3029. BAYNES MOTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB CIERTO
CIERTO I BRADFORD SKINNER WIENER
. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL STAY
ON CALL WITH ONE VOTE. HOPEFULLY
MORE TO COME. ALL RIGHT NEXT UP
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
KHN. WELCOME THANK YOU. YOU'RE
DOING AB 2099. I AM. AND THANK
YOU FOR PRONOUNCING MY NAME
RIGHT. DOESN'T HAPPEN A LOT
AROUND HERE. SO APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR EVEN IN HER ABSENTIA. AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS, I WILL START
BY SAYING I ACCEPT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AB 2099 PROTECTS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS BY PROVIDING AN UPDATE
TO THE PENALTIES FOR HARASSMENT
AND A VIOLATION OF PATIENTS
PRIVACY. SINCE ROE V WADE WAS
OVERTURNED, WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
HARASSING AND THREATENING THOSE
ACCESSING FUNDAMENTAL HEALTH
CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALTHOUGH I DID AN UPDATE TO THE
FACE ACT PRIOR TO THAT TIME,
THIS UPDATE IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE THAT ARE EXPRESSING
THEIR RIGHTS AND ACCESSING THAT
HEALTH CARE ARE SAFE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT. SO HOPEFULLY WE ALL
AGREE THAT NO MATTER WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITHIN CLINICS, THAT
THE SAFETY OF EVERYBODY IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE, WHICH IS REALLY THE
FOCUS OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. WITH ME HERE TODAY
ARE MOLLY ROBISON, VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD NORCAL
AND KIRSTEN CROWLEY BRANT, A
PATIENT ESCORT WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD MARMONTE. ALL RIGHT,
WELCOME TO THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH. COME ON UP.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS KIRSTEN CROWLEY. BRANT. I'VE
BEEN A VOLUNTEER WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD SINCE 2016 AND BECAME
A CLINIC PATIENT ESCORT IN
OCTOBER OF 2022, WHEN THE
PROGRAM RESUMED POST COVID AND
POST DOBBS DECISION. SINCE THEN,
I HAVE WITNESSED THE LENGTHS TO
WHICH CLINIC PROTESTERS WILL GO
TO HARASS, TORMENT AND
INTIMIDATE CLINIC PATIENTS,
STAFF AND VOLUNTEERS. IT IS THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF PROTESTERS TO
DETER AND ULTIMATELY BLOCK
PATIENTS FROM RECEIVING ANY KIND
OF SERVICES AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, AND THEY MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT TEST THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE FACE ACT TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL. AS SUCH, I HAVE BEEN I
HAVE SEEN PATIENTS SUBJECTED TO
A BARRAGE OF INFLAMMATORY VERBAL
TAUNTS AND HARASSMENT FOR THEIR
PERSONAL CHOICES. ON A DAY I WAS
VOLUNTEERING, I SAW A REGULAR
PROTESTER ENGAGE WITH A PATIENT
AND HER GRANDMOTHER. AS SOON AS
THE PATIENT EXITED HER CAR IN AN
ATTEMPT TO ENTER THE CLINIC, HE
BEGAN TO ENGAGE WITH HER. IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DELAY HER PROGRESS.
HE USED MALICIOUSLY PROVOCATIVE
LANGUAGE, CALLING HER NAMES AND
INSULTING HER RELIGIOUS BELIEFS,
HOPING FOR A RESPONSE EITHER IN
THE FORM OF SUBMISSION OR IN
SEARCH OF A HEATED CLASH TO FEED
HIS MYOPIC NARRATIVE THAT HIS
FELLOW PROTESTER COULD THEN
RECORD ON HIS GOPRO DEVICE. THIS
INCIDENT CAUSED THE PATIENT TO
FEEL SO INSECURE AND ESCALATED
TO HER NEEDING TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
TO ENTER THE HEALTH CENTER. I
HAVE ALSO SEEN CLINIC STAFF
SIMPLY LEAVING THE HEALTH CENTER
TO BE SCREAMED AT AND CALLED
MALICIOUS NAMES. I, ALONG WITH
MY FELLOW ESCORTS, HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO A CONTINUOUS STREAM
OF NAME CALLING AND HATEFUL
SPEECH ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND OUR
BELIEFS IN ATTEMPTS TO DISTRACT
US FROM HELPING THE PATIENTS.
PROTESTERS OFTEN TRY TO
INTIMIDATE US, USING THESE
TACTICS. ON ONE OCCASION, I
ARRIVED AT THE HEALTH CENTER AND
A PROTESTER WAS DRIVING IN
BEHIND ME. HE TOOK NOTE OF MY
CAR, AND HE PHOTOGRAPHED MY
LICENSE PLATE WITH MY COLLEGE
ALUMNI. FRAME ON IT. FOR THE
NEXT HOUR, HE PROCEEDED TO
LECTURE, HARASS, AND THREATEN
ME, USING THAT INFORMATION AS
AMMUNITION. AT THE END OF MY
SHIFT, HE HAD LEFT SEVERAL
INFORMATIONAL PAMPHLETS ON MY
CAR WINDSHIELD THAT INCIDENT HAS
CAUSED ME TO BE EXTRA CAUTIOUS
OF WHO'S DRIVING BEHIND ME AS I
ARRIVE OR LEAVE, OUT OF CONCERN
FOR MYSELF AND MY FAMILY. SINCE
PRESENTING TESTIMONY ON THE FACE
ACT TO A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY ONLY A FEW
MONTHS AGO, I HAVE SEEN THIS
TYPE OF FLAGRANT BEHAVIOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CLINIC. PROTESTERS
INCREASE AT AN ALARMING RATE.
THEY HAVE BECOME MORE EMBOLDENED
AND DETERMINED IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO INTIMIDATE AND HARASS
PATIENTS THROUGH THEIR
INCREASINGLY ELEVATED ABUSIVE
TACTICS. DESPITE CITY CODES AND
REGULATIONS, THEY ARE FINDING
LOOPHOLES AND TESTING THE
BOUNDARIES OF LEGAL LIMITS TO
ACHIEVE THEIR AGENDA, WHICH IS
SIMPLY TO DENY PEOPLE THEIR
LEGAL RIGHTS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. THEY SCREAM AND
SHOUT. THEY PHYSICALLY TEST THE
PROPERTY LINE WHEN THEY
CONFRONT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
VEHICLES. I GAVE YOU EXTRA TIME.
EVEN SO, SORRY, DIDN'T MEAN TO,
BUT ACTUALLY DID. THANK YOU. I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ÁP. I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
NEXT UP, SHE USED UP A HALF NO
THAT'S FINE, I'LL BE QUICK. GIVE
YOU YOUR FULL TWO MINUTES. NO
WORRIES. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. MOLLY ROBSON WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AB 2099, NARROWLY
UPDATES PENALTIES FOR JUST
VIOLATIONS OF THE FACE ACT,
WHICH IS MUCH NEEDED TO PROTECT
ACCESS TO CARE FOR PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT FEAR. I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND THE AUTHOR
FOR HER CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN
THIS ISSUE AREA, AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU GOT US RIGHT BACK ON
TRACK. SO, AT THIS TIME, ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES, IF
YOU COULD COME TO THE MICROPHONE
? IF NOT, THEN WE WILL TAKE THE
METOOS. ANYBODY WHO'S OPPOSING
OR, SUPPORTING THE BILL MAY COME
UP AND STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. MR. CHAIRMAN, DAN
FELIZARDO, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON BEHALF OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. VANESSA
CAJINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT
GENESIS GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELENI
KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, GEORGE FRAMPTON ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
, SEMINARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
SUPPORT. BRIAN SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS, DISTRICT NINE, IN
SUPPORT. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, EVERYBODY. THAT BRINGS IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. I MOVE THE
BILL AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING IT. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE BILL BY SENATOR
SKINNER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. MEMBERS,
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE ESCORT
WHO IS HERE TODAY, MISS KELLY,
WHO SHOWS UP EVERY DAY TO
PROTECT PATIENTS. THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS, COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
CARE IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS A
STATE, PRIORITIZE EVERY DAY. AND
ABORTION IS A PIECE OF THAT. AND
I WANT TO THANK HER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND ALL OF YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE WE PROTECT THOSE PATIENTS
AND PROVIDERS. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
I'M SORRY. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
FOR A ROLL CALL ITEM 9AB2099
BAUER-KAHAN MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB
SATO. SATO. NOT VOTING BRADFORD.
SKINNER SKINNER I WIENER OKAY.
THAT THAT THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. HOW'S THAT? ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP WE HAVE A VERY PATIENT
MR. BERMAN. THANK YOU. THERE'S
NO PLACE I'D RATHER BE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SATO, AND SENATORS
AND SENATOR SKINNER, OUR I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS. AB 1962 WOULD
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S LAW
AGAINST REVENGE BY CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLES IN THE CURRENT LAW
THAT MAY ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO
DISTRIBUTE PRIVATE SEXUAL IMAGES
OF ANOTHER PERSON WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT. REVENGE IS THE
ABHORRENT CRIME WHERE A PERSON
INTENTIONALLY DISTRIBUTES AN
INTIMATE IMAGE, KNOWING THAT IT
WILL CAUSE SERIOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS TO THE PERSON IN THE
IMAGE. THIS MOST OFTEN HAPPENS
WHEN A PERSON TEXTS, EMAILS, OR
POSTS AN INTIMATE PHOTO OR VIDEO
AS RETALIATION FOLLOWING A
BITTER BREAKUP BETWEEN PARTNERS.
WITH THE PREVALENCE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA, REVENGE IS BECOMING MORE
RAMPANT FROM 2016 TO 2020,
INCIDENTS OF REVENGE HAVE
DOUBLED, WITH 1 IN 12
INDIVIDUALS HAVING REPORTED
BEING A VICTIM OF REVENGE. A
STUDY FOUND THAT 93% OF VICTIMS
OF REVENGE SUFFERED SIGNIFICANT
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS, 51% HAD
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS, AND 49%
STATED THAT THEY HAD BEEN
STALKED OR HARASSED ONLINE BY
USERS WHO SAW THEIR IMAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE IMPETUS FOR
THIS BILL WAS A REVENGE CASE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. I REPRESENT
A PART OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY,
WHERE SOMEONE WAS LEFT WITHOUT
JUSTICE DUE TO OUR CURRENT LAWS.
THIS SHOWS THE URGENCY AND NEED
TO CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE. AB 1962
WOULD PROVIDE A NARROW FIX IN
THE STATUTE TO ENSURE THAT
VICTIMS OF REVENGE ARE
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED IN
CALIFORNIA AND HERE, WITH ME IS
JULIA SCHON, A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE WITNESS. WE
HAVE TWO MINUTES. PERFECT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JULIA
SCHOEN, AND I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH THE SANTA
CLARA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION.
AND I AM HERE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1962. WILL
STRENGTHEN THE PROTECTIONS OF
REVENGE VICTIMS BY CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLES IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE. REVENGE IS AN INVASIVE
CRIME THAT LARGELY VICTIMIZES
WOMEN, OFTEN IN THE CONTEXT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WITH THE
GROWING ADVANCEMENTS AND
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
SOCIAL MEDIA COMES NEW WAYS FOR
PERPETRATORS TO COMMIT THE
CRIME. AND THROUGH A SIMPLE
CLICK OF A BUTTON, PERPETRATORS
NOW HAVE A GLOBAL AUDIENCE,
LEADING TO EVEN MORE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS ON VICTIMS. AND YET
PERPETRATORS CAN STILL EXPLOIT
THE EXISTING LOOPHOLES IN THIS
STATUTE. ONE OF THESE LOOPHOLES
WAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF IN A
RECENT CASE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. A QUICK GOOGLE SEARCH OF
THE WOMAN'S NAME REVEALED AN
INTIMATE VIDEO OF HER, WHOSE
TITLE HAD HER FULL NAME, PLACE
OF EMPLOYMENT AND WHERE SHE
LIVED. A VIDEO SHE DID NOT KNOW
WAS EVEN TAKEN OR EXISTED, AND
THE PERPETRATOR WAS HER
EX-HUSBAND. UNDER THE EXISTING
LAW, THE CRIME OF REVENGE IS
AMBIGUOUS AS TO WHETHER IT
APPLIES TO INTIMATE IMAGES TAKEN
WITHOUT THE VICTIM'S KNOWLEDGE
OR CONSENT, AN AMBIGUITY THAT
ULTIMATELY LED THE WOMAN'S
EX-HUSBAND TO ESCAPE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION BECAUSE OF SOMEONE
DOESN'T KNOW IF A VIDEO WAS
RECORDED OR EVEN EXISTED, HOW
CAN THERE BE AN AGREEMENT OR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT SHALL
REMAIN PRIVATE? AND TO THIS DAY,
THIS WOMAN STILL LIVES IN FEAR
THAT HER FAMILY, FRIENDS AND
EMPLOYERS WILL ONE DAY DISCOVER
THIS VIDEO. A VIDEO THAT STILL
REMAINS ONLINE TO THIS DAY.
REVENGE HAS EVOLVED BEYOND THE
TYPICAL GIRL SENDS BOY PHOTO,
AND IT'S TIME FOR THE LAW TO
CATCH UP. AND WE APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE'S HELP AND
EFFECTUATING THIS CHANGE WITH
YOUR RECENT AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER LEAD UP? OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN FAVOR OF THE BILL?
IF NOT, WE'LL TAKE LEAD
OPPOSITION. IF THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION, WE'LL TAKE THE ME
TOOS IN FAVOR OR IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT,
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. GARRETT HAMILTON WITH
CD-R. JUST IN CASE THERE IS ANY
DOUBT BASED ON WHAT THE
TESTIMONY JUST WAS, WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE? IF THERE
IS NOBODY ELSE, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS FOR DISCUSSION
OR EMOTION. I MOVE THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
BY SENATOR SKINNER. MR. BERMAN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS. I
APPRECIATE MY WITNESS COMING UP
TO TESTIFY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT, SO
WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR A VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 1962, BY
BERMAN. MOTION WAS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB SATO. SATO I BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. THANK YOU. NEXT UP, WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TWO BILLS.
CORRECT. JOHN SAWYER AND A JOHN
SAWYER. YOU HAVE LIKE, THREE IF
YOU WANT TO SIT AT THE TABLE.
YEAH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO SIT AT
THE TABLE? ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES
GREAT. ALL RIGHT. WHICH OF THE
BILLS WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
FIRST? CAN I BEGIN WITH THAT,
JOHN SAWYER AB 3108. YOU MAY.
THANK YOU, SIR. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER, I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND ON HIS BEHALF.
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB 3108 WILL GIVE
VICTIMS OF PREDATORY MORTGAGE
LENDING A CHANCE TO ACHIEVE
JUSTICE BY CLARIFYING THAT
LENDERS WHO DECEIVE AND MISGUIDE
CONSUMERS ARE COMMITTING
MORTGAGE FRAUD. FOR MOST OF
THESE PEOPLE, THEIR ONLY ASSET
AND SOURCE OF EQUITY IS THEIR
HOME. PREDATORY MORTGAGES NOT
ONLY DRAIN THEIR HOME EQUITY,
BUT CAN ALSO LEAD TO INCREASED
DEBT, LOWER CREDIT SCORES AND
ULTIMATELY HOUSING INSECURITY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THESE CASES GO UNPROSECUTED.
AB 30 108 WILL CLARIFY THAT A
BROKER OR LOAN ORIGINATOR IS
COMMITTING MORTGAGE FRAUD IF
THEY CAUSE A BORROWER TO SIGN A
COMMERCIAL LOAN OR BRIDGE LOAN
WITH KNOWLEDGE THAT THE LOAN IS
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE BORROWER.
THIS WILL SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHT
THE NEEDS TO ADDRESS THESE CASES
AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE PREDATORY
BROKERS SO THAT VICTIMS OF
PREDATORY LENDING CAN ACHIEVE
JUSTICE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE ROBERT
HERRELL, ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
SPONSOR THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA, AND SAL VOSLER, A
CONSUMER ATTORNEY WITH
EXPERIENCE IN PREDATORY LENDING
CASES. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TODAY. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT AND YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT,
CORRECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR. VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, ROBERT HARRELL,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE, THIS MEASURE
REPRESENTS A COALITION BETWEEN
CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO CRACK DOWN ON
PREDATORY BROKERING FRAUD. A
LONG STORY SHORT, I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON CLARIFYING THE PENAL
CODE SECTION OF THE BILL. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT, THAT
EFFORT. WE THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY HELPFUL, THE SCAM THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS IS FOR FOLKS WHO ARE UNDER
SOME SORT OF FINANCIAL DURESS
AND POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOME. AND AGAIN,
THAT'S DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ONCE THE
NOTICE OF DEFAULT GOES OUT, THAT
BECOMES ESSENTIALLY AS A PUBLIC
DOCUMENT, A LEAD GENERATOR FOR
FRAUD AND THE FRAUD WE'VE BEEN
SEEING THE LAST FEW YEARS TAKES
TWO PARTICULAR FORMS. ONE IS
WHERE YOU FLIP OVER A CONSUMER
FROM THEIR RESIDENTIAL PRODUCT
INTO A COMMERCIAL PRODUCT. THE
PURPOSE BEING TO EVADE CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS THAT COVER THE
RESIDENTIAL AREA, BUT NOT SO
MUCH THE COMMERCIAL AREA. THE
OTHER WAY WE SEE IT IS THROUGH
BRIDGE LOANS, BUT THERE'S NOT
ANOTHER PURCHASE OF PROPERTY ON
THE OTHER END OF IT. SO THIS
WILL HELP US AND HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS CRACK DOWN ON THIS.
ALSO. IT WILL HELP FOLKS IN THE
PRIVATE SIDE WHO HAVE BEEN
RUNNING INTO THE PROBLEM, WHICH
IS THE IMMEDIATE QUESTION IS,
DID THE CONSUMER SIGN THE
PAPERWORK? EVEN IF THE PAPERWORK
WAS FRAUDULENT BY DESIGN AND
INTENDED TO DEFRAUD THE CONSUMER
WHO DID NOT KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
SIGNING, IN SOME CASES, ALL
KINDS OF LANGUAGE CHALLENGES AND
OTHERS. SO WE URGE AN AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
COALITION. I'M ALSO A PROXY ON
BEHALF OF, CRIME VICTIMS
ALLIANCE, WHICH WAS NOT LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS, BUT WHICH ALSO
SUPPORTS THE BILL. THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE YOU ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT? YES. I AM, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS PHIL VOSLER. I'M THE OWNER OF
THE VOSLER LAW FIRM, AND I
EXCLUSIVELY LITIGATE PREDATORY
LENDING AND WRONGFUL FORECLOSURE
LAWSUITS LEADING UP TO AND IN
THE WAKE OF THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS, CALIFORNIA AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S PASSED
PREDATORY LENDING PROHIBITIONS
THAT APPLY LARGELY TO CONSUMER
LOANS AND THOSE PROHIBITIONS
MOSTLY DO NOT APPLY TO
COMMERCIAL LOANS. SO BROKERS AND
LENDERS WHO ARE INTENDING TO
PREY ON A BORROWER WILL
INTENTIONALLY CAUSE THE BORROWER
TO SIGN A COMMERCIAL LOAN
DOCUMENT, EVEN IF THAT DOCUMENT
IS UNSUITABLE. A RECENT CLIENT I
TOOK IS 79 YEARS OLD. SHE'S AN
IMMIGRANT WIDOW WHO ONLY SPEAKS
FARSI. SHE MAKES $2,000 A MONTH,
AND HER BROKER STEERED HER INTO
HER INTO A LOAN THAT REQUIRED
HER TO PAY $1.4 MILLION IN ONE
YEAR. THEY CHARGED HER $150,000
IN FEES AND WHEN SHE DEFAULTED,
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, SHE
DEFAULTED, SHE COULDN'T AFFORD
THE LOAN. THE DEFAULT INTEREST
RATE WENT UP TO 25. THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN ILLEGAL IF IT WERE A
CONSUMER LOAN, BUT OF COURSE,
SHE SIGNED A COMMERCIAL LOAN
DOCUMENT, WHICH SHE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND. I'VE HAD OTHER
CLIENTS IN A COUPLE OF YEARS.
THAT CLIENT LOST HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF EQUITY.
I'VE HAD ANOTHER CLIENT WHO WAS
STEERED INTO FOUR OF THOSE LOANS
IN FOUR YEARS, AND SHE LOST HER
LIFE SAVINGS IN HOME EQUITY.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS IS MORTGAGE
FRAUD, SO THAT THE DA'S CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS AND HELP
THESE VICTIMS. WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. AT
THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE ANY
OPPOSITION LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WE HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS, INDIRA MCDONALD,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION, WE
CONTINUE A POSITION OF CONCERN.
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS,
AND THE INTENT TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE. HOWEVER, OUR CONCERNS
REMAIN BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT CURRENT LAW COVERS
THE CONDUCT DESCRIBED IN THE NEW
PROPOSED MORTGAGE FRAUD CRIMINAL
PROVISIONS ADDED BY SUBDIVISION
B, EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
BROAD APPLICABILITY AND IMPOSES
CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
DELIBERATELY FACILITATING A
MISSTATEMENT, MISREPRESENTATION
OR OMISSION DURING THE MORTGAGE
LENDING PROCESS WITH THE
INTENTION THAT IT BE RELIED ON
BY A MORTGAGE LENDER, BORROWER,
OR ANY OTHER PARTY TO THE
MORTGAGE LENDING PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA BANKERS AND MORTGAGE
BANKERS SUPPORTED ENACTMENT OF
PENAL CODE SECTION 532 F AS A
TOOL TO ATTACK FRAUD IN THE
MORTGAGE PROCESS THAT VICTIMIZED
LENDERS, INVESTORS, AND
BORROWERS. WE REMAIN SUPPORTIVE
OF ROBUST PROSECUTION IN THIS
AREA, BUT WE BELIEVE SECTION 532
F ALREADY PROVIDES A MEANS TO
ATTACK THE CONDUCT THAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS. SO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS THIS MORNING.
OKAY. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL TAKE
ANYBODY, ANY OF THE METOOS,
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. PLEASE COME
FORWARD, STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT,
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR YOU
OPPOSE. GARRETT HAMILTON WITH
CD-R IN SUPPORT. OKAY. IT LOOKS
LIKE THAT'S EXHAUSTS THE LINE OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING UP TO
SPEAK, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DÍAS FOR A MOTION OR
COMMENTS, I MOVE THE BILL.
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTING IT ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR. IT'S A
GOOD BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. ON BEHALF OF SENATOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES. SAWYER,
WE WISH YOU WELL. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND YOU MAY CALL ROLL
ITEM 8AB3108 JONES. SAWYER.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO I
SATO. I BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER I WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
THAT THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. DO YOU WANT TO
TACKLE AB 1186? YES. FIRST.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. GO TO THAT
AGAIN, GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING. I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR TIME
WORKING ON THIS BILL. OVER THE
LAST 18 MONTHS. I AUTHORED THIS
BILL BECAUSE OUR CURRENT YOUTH
RESTITUTION SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK
UNDER CURRENT STATE LAW. JUDGES
ORDER YOUTH TO PAY TWO TYPES OF
RESTITUTION. DIRECT RESTITUTION
OR MONETARY MONETARY
COMPENSATION TO A PERSON WHO HAS
EXPERIENCED LOSS OR INJURY DUE
TO A YOUNG PERSON'S ACTIONS.
RESTITUTION, FINES, MONETARY
PENALTIES RANGING FROM 100 TO
$1000, ORDERED AGAINST ANY YOUTH
ADJUDICATED OR PERSON CONVICTED
OF A CRIME, REGARDLESS IF THEY
CAUSED HARM. EACH YEAR AROUND
15,000 YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ORDERED TO PAY RESTITUTION
FINES. THESE FINES RANGE FROM
$100 TO $1000 PER ADJUDICATION.
ANY PORTION OF THESE FINES THAT
ARE COLLECTED GO TO THE STATE
RESTITUTION FUND, NOT CRIME
SURVIVORS. ONCE ORDERED TO PAY
RESTITUTION, YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE SUBJECT TO
UNFORGIVING COLLECTION PRACTICES
AND IRREVERSIBLE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES, INCLUDING NEGATIVE
CREDIT IMPACTS. BANK LEVIES, AND
EVEN PROPERTY LIENS. THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
OFTEN STRUGGLING ECONOMICALLY
AND ARE OFTEN SURVIVORS OF HARM
THEMSELVES. RESTITUTION, FINES
NOT ONLY CAUSE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
FOR MANY FAMILIES, IT CAN ALSO
STRAIN CRITICAL FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS, CREATING STRESS
AND STRIFE BETWEEN PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN. AT A TIME WHEN
THEY NEED THE MOST SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY, STUDIES SHOW THAT
MONETARY MONETARY SANCTIONS
AGAINST YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
RECIDIVISM OR THAT A YOUTH WILL
CAUSE HARM IN THE FUTURE. THE
LIKELIHOOD INCREASES WITH EACH
ADDITIONAL DOLLAR ASSESSED.
YOUTH RESTITUTION DEBT IS ALSO
EXPENSIVE TO COLLECT BECAUSE
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH AND
FAMILIES SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY PUBLIC RECORDS. ACT REQUESTS
REVEAL THAT COUNTIES SPEND $1.22
TO RECOUP EACH DOLLAR OF YOUTH
RESTITUTION FINE DEBT. TO ADD TO
THIS, MOST RESTITUTION FINE,
DEBT HOLDERS OLDER THAN THREE
YEARS WILL LIKELY NEVER BE PAID,
REGARDLESS OF THE COLLECTION
METHOD. ON TOP OF THE BURDENS
FAMILIES FACE WITH THESE
RESTITUTION FINES, YOUTH FACE,
OTHER INEQUITIES IN OUR CURRENT
RESTITUTION SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN YOUTH ARE HELD JOINTLY AND
SEVERALLY LIABLE FOR HARM
CAUSED, A YOUNG PERSON MAY
SATISFY THEIR PORTION OF THE
DEBT AND STILL FACE PAYING WELL
BEYOND THEIR SHARE OF LIVING THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES WITH THIS
DEBT AND COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES, AB 1186 THE REPAIR
REVITALIZING, REALIZING EQUITY
WHILE PROMOTING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND IMPACTFUL RELIEF ACT HELPS
MAKE OUR RESTITUTION SYSTEM WORK
MORE EQUITABLY. AB 1186 DOES THE
FOLLOWING. FIRST, IT ELIMINATES
YOUTH RESTITUTION FINES. IT ALSO
VACATES OLD AND THEREFORE
LARGELY UNCOLLECTIBLE
RESTITUTION. FINE DEBT ENDS WAGE
AND TRUST ACCOUNT GARNISHMENT
FOR YOUTH RESTITUTION CLARIFIES
LOSS CALCULATIONS FOR PROPERTY
REPAIR OR REPLACEMENT FOR YOUTH,
RESTITUTION ORDERS AND ENDS.
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY FOR
YOUTH CODEFENDANTS. AB 1186
MAKES OUR RESTITUTION SYSTEM
WORK BETTER FOR YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU AND HIS
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY. I HAVE,
LARIOS WITH COURAGE AND DELANEY
GREEN WITH A POLICY ADVOCACY
CLINIC AT BERKELEY LAW. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, WITNESSES, FOR
APPEARING THIS MORNING. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SOCHI
LARIOS. I'M A JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATOR FOR COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH
JUSTICE. WE ARE A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 1186. I HAVE
BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE
DELINQUENCY AND DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM SINCE I WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
IN 2017, I FACED ONE OF MY
LONGEST LOCKUPS WHERE I WAS
INCARCERATED FOR 200 PLUS DAYS
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY'S JUVENILE
JUSTICE CENTER. I WAS RELEASED
INTO TRANSITIONAL HOUSING UNDER
ASSEMBLY BILL 12. I HAD JUST
TURNED 18. I DID NOT HAVE
SUPPORT FROM MY FAMILY. I DID
NOT HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY CARD,
A BIRTH CERTIFICATE, A CAR, A
LICENSE OR GUIDANCE FROM
PROBATION ON REENTRY. I ALSO
SUFFERED FROM PTSD. ON TOP OF
THIS, I WAS ORDERED TO PAY
$3,000 IN RESTITUTION AND
RESTITUTION, FINES AND THE
VARIOUS RESTITUTION RELATED FEES
AND SURCHARGES FOR THE HARM THAT
I HAVE CAUSED. WHEN YOU RECEIVE
A BILL, A BILL FOR COURT DEBT,
EACH ADDITIONAL DOLLAR COUNTS
AND RESTITUTION, FINES AND FEES
MAKE IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
STAY AFLOAT. MEET THE
RESTITUTION ORDER OBLIGATIONS,
AND ACHIEVE REHABILITATION. IF
MY RESTITUTION RELATED DEBT WAS
NOT PAID, IT WOULD HAVE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED MY CREDIT.
IT IS RARE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
STAY OUT OF THE JUVENILE SYSTEM
WITH SUCH EXTREME BURDENS PUT ON
THEM AND NOT ONLY MADE THE
RESTITUTION MONTHLY PAYMENTS
BECAUSE I PUT MY EDUCATION ON
HOLD, WORKED MORE HOURS AND
RECEIVED AN HONORARIUM WHICH WAS
IMMEDIATELY, IMMEDIATELY
GARNISHED, WE KNOW THAT THE
SYSTEM ISN'T WORKING FOR KIDS
AND ISN'T WORKING FOR SURVIVORS.
AB 1186 IS A STEP TOWARDS
CREATING A MORE CONSTRUCTIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEM OF YOUTH
RESTITUTION IN CALIFORNIA. BY
REDUCING THE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
ECONOMIC BURDENS ON YOUTH AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE WHO ARE LARGELY
UNABLE TO PAY. WHILE WE STILL
HAVE MORE AND LOTS TO DO TO
ADDRESS THE RESTITUTION SYSTEM,
WE. I KINDLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL AND IMPACT
AND IMPACTFUL BILL AS A FIRST
STEP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DELANEY GREEN. I'M WITH THE UC
BERKELEY POLICY ADVOCACY CLINIC
AT THE BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL. I AM
HERE TO PROVIDE ANY, TECHNICAL
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. I KNOW IT
CAN BE A LITTLE BIT TRICKY, BUT
I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYONE'S TIME THIS MORNING. SO
JUST WANTED TO DEFER TO IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS AND
OTHERWISE GIVE BACK THE TIME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. AT
THIS TIME WE'LL TAKE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ANYBODY
OPPOSING THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND SPEAK AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS. IF NOT, THEN WE'LL GO
TO ME. TWOS. COME ON UP. STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL WITH THE CHAIRS
INDULGENCE. I'D LIKE TO READ OFF
A LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT. READ QUICKLY. THANK
YOU. YES THANK YOU. THE MAVEN
COLLABORATIVE FREEDOM FOR YOUTH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. ALL OF US ARE
NONE. LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, SAN FRANCISCO.
INVISIBLE CALIFORNIA, STAY
STRONG. KAWHI CK COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE,
SAN FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT, ROOT AND REBOUND
EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION, RESTORING HOPE,
CALIFORNIA EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER, UNIVERSITY OF THE
PACIFIC, MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW,
HOMELESS ADVOCACY CLINIC,
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET, WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW, AND POVERTY, THE
RUBICON PROGRAMS, ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR UNIVERSIDAD POPULAR,
SAN FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT, ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION,
SANTA CRUZ, BARRIOS UNIDOS,
CHÁVEZ POLICY RESEARCH COMMUNITY
WORKS, UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE AT UC BERKELEY, YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER, RISE
UNITED CORE ALLIANCE, THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, CAREFIRST, CALIFORNIA
FRESH LIFELINES FOR YOUTH,
FRESNO BARRIOS UNIDOS, THE UNITY
COUNCIL, DIGNITY AND POWER, NOW,
SURGE BAY AREA W, HAYWARD BURNS
INSTITUTE, THE CHAT PROJECT,
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER, LA
DEFENSA, SAFE RETURN PROJECT,
DEBT COLLABORATIVE, DIGNITY AND
POWER NOW AND FINALLY,
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE PROUD CO-SPONSOR. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. I BET THAT
COVERS EVERYBODY. SO THANK YOU
ALL KNOW COME ON UP. DIDN'T
CATCH US ANTHONY RATCLIFFE WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KELLY O'BRIEN
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GARRETT HAMILTON WITH
KDA. WITH THE RECENT AMENDS WE
ARE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AND
GOING NEUTRAL. ERIC HENDERSON,
ON BEHALF OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT, LAWRENCE
COX ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
ALL OF US ARE IN SUPPORT.
TATIANA LEWIS WITH THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BARBARA CHÁVEZ WITH THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. JENNIFER PENROSE WITH
POWER IN UNITY AND DIRECTLY
IMPACTED IN FULL SUPPORT. LAURA
LARIOS WITH INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ROSA ORTEZ
LUCERO I SUPPORT, RICO LOPEZ ON
THE BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY.
FULLY SUPPORT BERNICE SINGH
ROGERS OUTSIDE ORGANIZER WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND INMATE
FAMILY COUNCIL AT SALINAS
VALLEY. I STRONGLY SUPPORT HENRY
ORTIZ LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS AND CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US IN SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LESLIE
CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. OKAY. WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS
FOR DISCUSSION OR A MOTION. I
MOVE THE BILL AND APPRECIATE
THIS. AN IMPORTANT BILL. AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU. I THINK
THIS BILL VERY APTLY RECOGNIZES
THAT OUR YOUTH RESTITUTION
SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND ALLOWS US
TO BE ABLE TO PUT OUR USEFUL AND
VERY IMPORTANT, COUNTY DOLLARS
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT WE'RE
CREATING A PATH FOR BOTH
MEANINGFUL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
HEALING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IMPACTED, AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
NOT BURDEN YOUTH WITH THE DEBT
THAT COMES WITH DEBT THAT THEY
CANNOT AFFORD. AND, AND THAT
CONTINUES TO BE HARMFUL. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. GOOD.
THANK YOU. AND, WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND CALL ROLL ITEM NUMBER ONE,
AB 1186 BONTA. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS BILL. HOB.
SATO. SATO NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. THAT BRINGS US TO YOUR
LAST BILL. AB 2709, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GO AHEAD. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. SENATOR AND
MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. AB 2709 IS
SHAPED BY THE FIRSTHAND
EXPERIENCES OF FAMILIES WITH
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES. IT'S
CRUCIAL TO RECOGNIZE THE
PROFOUND IMPACT THAT MAINTAINING
A FAMILY CONNECTION HAS ON AN
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL, NOT
ONLY FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
WELL-BEING, BUT ALSO FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION INTO
OUR SOCIETY UPON RELEASE, AS
WELL AS THE IMPORTANCE THAT IT
HAS ON THEIR LOVED ONES WHO ARE
LEFT BEHIND. FIRSTLY, AB 2709
PROHIBITS VISITS DENIAL DUE TO
MINOR OMISSIONS OR INACCURACIES
ON VISITOR APPLICATIONS.
SECONDLY, AB 2709 CODIFIES THREE
DAYS OF IN-PERSON VISITATION PER
WEEK ALONGSIDE VIDEO CALLS.
THIRDLY, THIS BILL PROHIBITS
STRIP SEARCHES OF MINORS WITH
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS. AND FINALLY,
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES
FOR USING REASONABLE SCREENING
IN THE CASE OF PROBABLE CAUSE
FOR A SEARCH, SUCH AS MEDICAL
METAL DETECTORS, BODY SCANNERS,
AND OTHER TYPES OF AVAILABLE
SCREENING TECHNOLOGIES FOR
VISITORS BEFORE A STRIP SEARCH.
THIS BILL UNDERSCORES THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAINTAINING FAMILY
CONNECTIONS DURING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES, AS HIGHLIGHTED
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC, MY
OFFICE HAS COMMUNICATED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE REACHED
OUT WITH CONCERNS, AND WE ARE
ACTIVELY CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
CSPOA AND CDCR. AB 2709 IS VITAL
FOR PRESERVING FAMILY
CONNECTIONS FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS LAWRENCE COX, THE
REGIONAL ADVOCACY AND ORGANIZING
ASSOCIATE AND INTERIM
COORDINATOR OF THE COALITION FOR
FAMILY UNITY, AND HEATHER
O'MALLEY, AN ORGANIZER WITH
ORGANIZER WITH FUEL. SAME DRILL
AS BEFORE. YOU GOT TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. NOT TWO AND A HALF. I
ONLY GAVE THAT TO ONE PERSON.
AND THEN. OKAY, WELL, AS THE
MEMBER SAID, THIS BILL IS
IMPERATIVE. LIKE I SAID EARLIER,
REMOVING BARRIERS FOR VISITING
FOR THOSE THAT ARE INCARCERATED
IN THEIR LOVED ONES IS KEY TO
DECREASING RECIDIVISM AND
HELPING REHABILITATE THOSE THAT
ARE INCARCERATED, IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR FAMILIES TO BE
ABLE TO COME VISIT. SO THAT
STARTS WITH THE VISITING
APPLICATION. IF THERE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS IN THAT
APPLICATION THAT SERVE NO
PENOLOGICAL INTEREST, I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE ALL SHOULD AGREE
THAT THEY SHOULD BE REMOVED,
THAT INCLUDES THE PROCESS WHEN
INDIVIDUALS COME TO VISIT THEIR
LOVED ONES. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE SHOULD BE UNNECESSARY,
UNHUMAN. INHUMANE. EXCUSE ME?
DEGRADING PROCESSES THAT ARE
PLACED IN UTILIZED AS BARRIERS
JUST BECAUSE OF REASONABLE
SUSPICION IN ORDER TO DO SO. AND
I'M SPEAKING OF STRIP SEARCHING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN, WHICH HAS
BECOME A PRACTICE THAT WE WANT
AS A POPULATION AND AS A
COMMUNITY TO KIND OF WRANGLE IN
AND REMOVE A BARRIER THAT'S
UNNECESSARY HINDRANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS FEELING COMFORTABLE
AND FEELING DIGNIFIED WHEN THEY
COME VISIT THEIR LOVED ONES. AND
I WANT TO CLOSE WITH SAYING
VISITING IS KEY TO
REHABILITATION. I WOULDN'T BE
WHO I AM NOW. I WOULDN'T BE
WHERE I WAS AT, WHERE I AM NOW,
IF I HAD NOT HAD ACCESS TO MY
FAMILY, IF I HAD NOT BEEN ABLE
TO SPEND WEEKENDS WITH THEM.
I'VE SPENT 17 YEARS OF THE LAST
19 YEARS OF MY LIFE
INCARCERATED, AND I COME HOME AS
IN A FINISHED NOT UNFINISHED,
SHOULD I SAY REHABILITATIVE.
INDIVIDUAL WHO ORGANIZES AND
COORDINATES ALL EIGHT OF OUR
ACTIVE CHAPTERS OF ALL OF US
THROUGHOUT THE STATES AND
COORDINATES 30 OTHER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND ADVOCACY WORK.
SO I THINK I SAY ALL THAT JUST
TO SAY I'M PROOF THAT
REHABILITATION EXISTS. AND THAT
VISITING IS KEY AND IMPERATIVE
TO REHABILITATION. GREAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING. NEXT PERSON,
ANYBODY ELSE COMING UP? YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
2709, AS AMENDED ON JUNE 19TH OF
THIS YEAR. MY NAME IS HEATHER
O'MALLEY. AND MY LOVED ONE HAS
BEEN INCARCERATED IN CDCR FOR
OVER 30 YEARS. I AM SPEAKING TO
YOU AS A VISITOR WHO WAS
SUBJECTED TO AN UNWARRANTED AND
IMPROPER CDCR STRIP SEARCH, AN
EXPERIENCE THAT WAS HUMILIATING,
DEGRADING, DEHUMANIZING, AND
EXTREMELY TRAUMATIC. CDCR'S
UPDATED STRIP POLICIES. STRIP
SEARCH POLICY MAKES IT EASIER
FOR CDCR TO SUBJECT OTHER
VISITORS, INCLUDING WOMEN,
CHILDREN, ELDERLY, AND VISITORS
WITH DISABILITIES, TO THE SAME
TRAUMA, HUMILIATION, AND
DEHUMANIZATION. I EXPERIENCED.
VISITORS ARE TOLD THAT A CONSENT
TO A STRIP SEARCH IS VOLUNTARY.
HOWEVER IF WE REFUSE TO SUBMIT
TO A STRIP SEARCH, OUR VISIT
WILL BE DENIED AND WE WON'T BE
ALLOWED TO VISIT OUR LOVED ONE.
THE POLICY ALSO ALLOWS CDCR TO
MAKE FUTURE VISITS CONDITIONED
UPON OUR WILLINGNESS TO SUBMIT
TO A STRIP SEARCH FOR AN
INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME.
IMAGINE HAVING TO CONSENT TO A
TSA STRIP SEARCH AT THE AIRPORT
IN ORDER TO PASS THROUGH AND
BOARD YOUR FLIGHT, BECAUSE
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A BUTTON
ON YOUR PANTS OR A CLASP ON YOUR
BRA SET OFF THE METAL DETECTOR.
WELL, THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING
CURRENTLY TO VISITORS, INCLUDING
CHILDREN, DUE TO CDCR VISITOR
STRIP SEARCH POLICY, NO ONE
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO CONSENT TO
BE TO BEING HUMILIATED AND
DEHUMANIZED AS A CONDITION TO
VISIT THEIR LOVED ONE,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF VISITING AND ITS POSITIVE
IMPACT ON REHABILITATION,
STUDIES SHOW, AND I PERSONALLY
KNOW, VISITING BUILDS BONDS AND
STRENGTHENS FAMILY UNITY. I GREW
UP THE CHILD OF AN INCARCERATED
PARENT, AND VISITS WERE A
LIFELINE TO MY FATHER AND TO ME.
VISITING ALSO HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
ENCOURAGE PROSOCIAL BEHAVIOR,
DECREASE RECIDIVISM, AND
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK
YOU, MA'AM FOR THAT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING. OKAY. NEXT UP WE HAVE
ME TOOS. THOSE THAT ARE IN FAVOR
OR OPPOSED. OH, DID I DO
OPPOSITION? I DID NOT DO
OPPOSITION YET. SO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. COME ON UP. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MATT EASLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION, I WOULD LIKE TO
STATE THAT A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL ARE VERY
POSITIVE, AND WE DO STRONGLY
SUPPORT INCREASED ACCESS TO
VISITATION WHENEVER POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF THE
REASONS AND EXPLANATIONS ALREADY
MENTIONED. AND THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS ON THIS
BILL. ALL OF THEM HAVE BEEN
POSITIVE. UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE
STILL NOT QUITE THERE YET WITH A
NUMBER OF ISSUES, THE FIRST
BEING THE RESTRICT THE, THE, THE
VERY NARROW LIST OF REASONS WHY
AN INMATE CAN HAVE, OR CAN BE
RESTRICTED ON VISITATION AND THE
NOT USING, NOT BEING ABLE TO USE
ANY DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS FOR
ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF, OUTSIDE OF
THE ACTUAL VISITING ROOM IS
PROBLEMATIC. NOW THERE'S,
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF RULE
VIOLATIONS THAT I THINK SHOULD
NOT BE USED TO LIMIT VISITATION,
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER THAT
WOULD, WE THINK, INCREASE THE
RISK AND SAFETY CONCERNS TO NOT
JUST OTHER INMATES, BUT THE
VISITORS AS WELL. OUR STAFF IN
THE VISITATION ROOM. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN IN THE VISITATION ROOM,
IF, IF AN INMATE WAS TO COMMIT
AN ACT OF VIOLENCE ON THE WAY TO
VISITATION OR AN HOUR PRIOR TO
VISITATION, THAT PERSON CLEARLY
AT THIS MOMENT IS NOT IN A
STEADY STATE OF MIND TO CREATE A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL THOSE
AROUND THEM. ACCORDING TO THIS
BILL, WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
RESTRICT ANY VISITATION. AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S ONE ISSUE
THAT COULD BE RESOLVED FAIRLY
SIMPLY BY ENABLING WHICH THIS
BILL PREVENTS ENABLING, MAYBE
THAT A VISITOR CAN HAVE BE
RESTRICTED TO NON CONTACT VISITS
INSTEAD OF CONTACT VISITS. BUT A
LARGER ISSUE LIKE THAT IS A
MAJOR CONCERN FOR US. I THINK IT
CREATES SAFETY ISSUES FOR
EVERYONE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOUR TWO MINUTES.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP AS A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION? IF NOT, WE'LL HAVE
THE ME TOO'S LIKE I STARTED
BEFORE AND THEN STOPPED. SORRY
ABOUT THAT, LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT.
YACHTY WITH OAKLAND PRIVACY AND
SUPPORT. WE DIDN'T GET A LETTER
IN TIME CONSTRAINTS. TATIANA
LOUIS WITH THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BARBARA
CHÁVEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NO. NO LIST,
NO LIST. AND LITTLE. AND LITTLE.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. I ASKED THE SAME THING.
ERIC HENDERSON ON BEHALF OF GRIP
TRAINING INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT
SAFE, KATRINA REESE ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. JENNIFER PENROSE WITH
POWER AND UNITY AND DIRECTLY
IMPACTED IN FULL SUPPORT. LARA
LARIOS WITH INITIATE JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. RICO LOPEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY,
STRONGLY SUPPORT BERNICE ROGERS,
OUTSIDE ORGANIZER WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE AND FAMILY COUNCIL AT
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON.
STRONGLY SUPPORT ROSA ORTEZ
LUCERO AS A MOTHER OF AN
INCARCERATED SON IN SALINAS
STATE PRISON. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ON THIS. GOOD MORNING, HENRY
ORTIZ WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
SACRAMENTO, ALL OF US AND UN
CHAPTER AND COMMUNITY HEALERS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THIS BILL? I MOVE THE BILL.
DO I HAVE TO GO TO A PROBE? SO I
WILL MAKE IT THE MOTION AND
THEY'LL COME BACK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND, WITH THAT, I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS. YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE'RE
HAVING IN OUR PRISONS, AS YOU
KNOW, IS IT JUST SEEMS WE CAN'T
GET A HANDLE ON THE RAMPANT DRUG
USE. SO HAVE YOU HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH CDCR AND, YOU
KNOW, OTHER PRISON SYSTEMS THAT
WOULD, YOU KNOW, THE COUNTY
PRISONS AND, OUR COUNTY JAILS
THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED BY YOUR
BILL? AND, YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO THESE RESTRICTIONS
AND HOW HOW DO WE STOP PEOPLE
FROM SMUGGLING DRUGS IN IF THEY
CAN'T CHECK TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
DRUGS? AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM. I KNOW OUR
NEWSPAPERS IN OUR AREA LIKE TO
MAKE A HUGE ORDEAL WHEN, YOU
KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY, AN INMATE
MAY DIE FROM A DRUG OVERDOSE
OVERNIGHT, YOU KNOW, THE GUARDS
AREN'T THERE 24 OVER SEVEN TO
WATCH THEM, AND, THEY GET THE
DRUG SOMEHOW, USUALLY FROM
VISITATION. WE DON'T KNOW. YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES IT COULD BE
INTERNAL, BUT HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THAT GIVEN THESE RESTRICTIONS
WITHOUT IT GOING UP AND BECAUSE
I KNOW DURING COVID THAT NUMBER
OF DRUG ODS IN PRISON WENT WAY
DOWN AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
VISITORS. SO THERE'S THAT
PROBLEM. AND, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT, YOU KNOW, I'M
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT BECAUSE
I'D LIKE THE PRISON POPULATION
TO BE ABLE TO BE REHABILITATED
AND RETURNED, NOT IN A BODY BAG.
AND, AND SO, HOW HAVE YOU RUN
ACROSS THOSE QUESTIONS AND HOW
HAVE YOU ADDRESSED THOSE? YEAH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. AND I
APPRECIATE, THE ABILITY TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL DIALOG WITH YOU. I
APPRECIATED SERVING WITH YOU ON
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH CDCR. I
THINK, ON THIS AND I ALSO DID
SERVE AS THE BUDGET SUB CHAIR
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY LAST YEAR. AND
THE DATA THAT WE REVIEWED
ESSENTIALLY SHOWED THAT DURING
COVID, THERE WAS AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF THE AMOUNT OF
CONTRABAND THAT WAS COMING
THROUGH, AND THAT WAS AT A TIME
WHEN THERE WERE NO FAMILY
CONTACT VISITS HAPPENING. SO I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT OUR, THAT
THERE IS CONTRABAND FREELY
COMING INTO OUR PRISONS, AND WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
DYING. WE DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE
RAMPANT. DRUG USE AND DRUG ABUSE
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM. THAT'S NOT
WHY THEY EXIST. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE THAT THE IMPACT OF
FAMILY VISITATIONS IS WHAT IS
BELIEVED TO BE IN THE, IN THE
MEDIA AND KIND OF OUT THERE THE
DATA ACTUALLY CONTROVERTS THAT
BELIEF AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR,
OUR, OUR PRISON GUARDS AND OUR
AND OUR INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE
SAFE AND THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REHABILITATE USING FAMILY
VISITATION AS A MEANS TO
PUNITIVELY, ENGAGE AN
INCARCERATED PERSON IS NOT THE
ANSWER TO PROVIDING THAT KIND OF
SAFETY. THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY
ENSURES THAT WE HAVE AN ABILITY
TO BE MEASURED IN, IN, ENSURING
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH CCPOA AND CDCR TO STRIKE
THAT RIGHT BALANCE. BUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW RIGHT NOW IS THAT IT IS
FAR TOO, LEANING FAR TOO MUCH
TOWARDS A PUNITIVE RESPONSE AND
TAKING AWAY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
USE FAMILY CONTACT AND FAMILY
VISITATION AS A MEANS TO
REHABILITATE. AND I STARTED THIS
, JOURNEY OUT WORKING ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE I WAS TALKING TO A
LOT OF FAMILIES WHO HAD PEOPLE
WHO WERE INCARCERATED AND WHO
WERE STRUGGLING BECAUSE THEY
WERE SEEING THE TIES WITH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WERE INSIDE
BEING FRAYED. AND SEEING THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS BEING LOST TO
THEM. AND FEELING THE LOSS OF
THAT AS IF SOMEONE HAD DIED
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT CONNECTION, OR
BECAUSE THAT CONNECTION WAS
UNCERTAIN. THEY COULD SHOW UP TO
PRISON, EXPECTING TO BE ABLE TO
BE VISITED, TRAVEL LONG
DISTANCE, TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT,
AND THEN BE TOLD AT THE DROP OF
A DIME, YOU CAN'T SEE THE PERSON
THAT YOU TRAVELED ALL THIS WAY
AND WAITED TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
THAT'S NOT OKAY EITHER. SO THIS.
AND THEN I GOT A CHANCE TO TALK
TO PEOPLE WHO WERE INSIDE AND
RECOGNIZED HOW INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IT WAS FOR THEM WHILE
THEY WERE WAITING YEARS AND
YEARS FOR BASIC PROGRAMING AND
REHABILITATIVE SUPPORT TO HAVE
THE ONE THING THAT IS SURE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
A WAY TO BE ABLE TO CONNECT, AND
THAT IS THROUGH FAMILY
VISITATION AND FAMILY CONTACTS.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE BALANCE OF
THIS NOTION OF BROADER SAFETY. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT WE CANNOT
SACRIFICE THE REHABILITATIVE
POWER FOR BOTH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED AND THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WAITING AND LOVING THEIR
INCARCERATED, BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND FATHERS AND UNCLES
AND MOTHERS WHO ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE SYSTEM. SO I WILL USE THAT
AS MY CLOSE. I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY, YOU WANT TO USE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES? I WILL ABSOLUTELY
USE THAT AS MY CLOTHES. I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
CENTER ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR A
VOTE. ITEM 16 AB 2709 BONTA
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SATO. SATO.
NÓ. BRADFORD. SKINNER. WIENER
OKAY. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. AND I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
MURATSUCHI. Ó. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COME UP AND BE THE SOLE? I
CAN'T GIVE YOU A MOTION, BUT I
CAN LISTEN TO YOUR YOUR BILL.
YEAH I WISH I COULD, BUT I CAN'T
ALL RIGHT. MR. MURATSUCHI, THIS
IS AB 2309. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, IF I
MAY, I THIS, ENTER THE ROOM,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, VICE CHAIR
SATO. THIS IS A BILL. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2309. THAT ORIGINALLY WAS
PROPOSING TO, ALLOW GENERAL LAW
CITIES THE SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT
CHARTER CITIES HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO PROSECUTE STATE LAW
MISDEMEANORS, SINCE THEN, I'VE
ENGAGED IN A VERY GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND WITH MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND I HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED THIS BILL
TO LIMIT THE PROSECUTORS, THE
CITY PROSECUTORS OF GENERAL LAW,
CITIES TO BE ABLE TO PROSECUTE
CASES ONLY IN COLLABORATIVE
JUSTICE COURTS, AS THIS
COMMITTEE WELL KNOWS,
COLLABORATIVE JUSTICE COURTS ARE
KNOWN AS PROBLEM SOLVER COURTS
AND IN PARTICULAR, THE MAIN
PROPONENT OF THIS BILL, THE CITY
OF MANHATTAN BEACH IN MY
DISTRICT, THEIR INTEREST IS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A MORE PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO DEAL WITH THEIR
LOCAL HOMELESS POPULATION. THE
HOMELESS COURTS. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE, NOT
ONLY FROM THE CHIEF OF POLICE OF
MANHATTAN BEACH, CHIEF RACHEL
JOHNSON, BUT ALSO OUR
NEIGHBORING REDONDO BEACH CITY
ATTORNEY, MICHAEL WEBB, WHERE IN
REDONDO, THEY HAVE DEMONSTRATED
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN REDUCING
THEIR HOMELESS POPULATION USING
THE HOMELESS COURTS. NOT TO
PUNISH POVERTY, NOT TO
CRIMINALIZE POVERTY, BUT TO
PROVIDE THE YOUTH THE CRIMINAL
COURTS, AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO
HELP SUPPORT AND, GET THE
UNHOUSED BACK ON THEIR FEET
USING THE OPPORTUNITY OF THE
MINOR LOW LEVEL STATE LAW,
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES THAT BRING
THEM INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD WITH YOUR PERMISSION, VICE
CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO CALL CHIEF
JOHNSON AND CITY ATTORNEY
MICHAEL WEBB TO TESTIFY AT THE
WITNESS TABLE, GREAT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THEM TESTIFY UP
HERE AT THE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. AND I. I'LL ASK HIM,
ARE YOU GOING TO BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS? YES, ABSOLUTELY. AND
I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS, THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
HAS REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S ASSOCIATION, VICE
CHAIR. HOPE TO EARN YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
WITNESSES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. SO IF YOU CAN MAKE IT TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. GOOD MORNING, VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RACHEL
JOHNSON. I'M THE CHIEF OF POLICE
FOR THE CITY OF MANHATTAN BEACH.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION, WHO IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AS A POLICE CHIEF.
IT'S MY PRIMARY DUTY TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY. IT'S
ALSO MY RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
OUR OFFICERS ARE JUDICIOUS IN
SITUATIONS THAT REQUIRE THEIR
INTERVENTION. AND THAT IS WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT. FROM MY
STANDPOINT, PROTECTING PEOPLE
AND FINDING A BALANCE BETWEEN
ENFORCEMENT AND PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE WHO NEED
HELP. ASSEMBLY BILL 2309 WILL
HELP ENSURE WE CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES BY
ADDRESSING ILLEGAL CONDUCT
THROUGH COLLABORATIVE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES AND
JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN DOING SO,
OUR CITY WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO UTILIZE DIVERSION AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO CORRECT
BEHAVIOR WITHOUT RELYING ON
PENALTIES ALONE. FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THIS MORNING. NEXT
SPEAKER, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MIKE WEBB.
I'M THE CITY ELECTED CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF REDONDO
BEACH. IT'S A CHARTER CITY. THIS
BILL DOESN'T AFFECT US, BUT I
FLEW UP HERE FROM VACATION TO
SPEAK IN ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF
THIS, BECAUSE IT'S VERY MUCH
NEEDED, ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE SUPREME COURT'S, GRANTS PASS
VERSUS JOHNSON SITUATION, CODE
ENFORCEMENT ANTI-CAMPING WILL BE
CAN BE PROSECUTED UNDER GRANTS
PASS VERSUS JOHNSON BY CITY
ATTORNEYS. AND THAT WOULD DUMP
THEM ALL INTO CRIMINAL COURT.
THIS BILL CREATES A PREFERENCE
FOR COLLABORATIVE COURTS. AND
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS. WE ARE
ON THE VERGE AND AS, ASSESSED BY
OUR SOUTH BAY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS, OF REACHING
FUNCTIONAL ZERO IN HOMELESSNESS
FROM A DECADE LONG HIGH. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE PROVIDE, WE
HAD THE FIRST OUTDOOR HOMELESS
COURT IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
LIVE, WHERE THEY FREQUENT. AND
WE SET UP THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES, ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES FOR THOSE WHO
NEED THEM, ADDITIONAL DRUG
ADDICTION AND ALCOHOL ADDICTION
SERVICES FOR THOSE WHO NEED THEM
IN A VERY NON-THREATENING
MANNER. THE BEST DESCRIPTION OF
IT ISN'T MINE. IT CAME FROM AN
ASSISTANT HEAD PUBLIC DEFENDER
WHO SAID IT'S A REAL COURT IN
THE ATMOSPHERE OF A RESOURCE
FAIR, AND SO WE TRY AND SET THEM
UP FOR SUCCESS. AND SO I THINK
WITH GRANTS PASS, WE DON'T WANT
TO DUMP A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM,
TRADITIONAL BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
PROSECUTE SOMEONE TO OVERCOME
THE OBSTACLES TO RECEIVING
HOMELESSNESS. AND IT'S ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY AND WOULD BE UNDER
THIS BILL IF THEY DON'T WANT IT,
THEN IT WOULD RETURN TO,
CRIMINAL COURT IN THE DA. SO
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME ON
THIS, AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS COMING TO
TESTIFY. THIS MORNING. NEXT UP,
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN LEAD
OPPOSITION? IF THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS,
THEN WE'LL TAKE THE METOOS AT
THIS TIME. COME ON UP. SUPPORT
THE STATE. YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. YOU
REPRESENT. LESLIE CALDWELL,
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE
ARE WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION.
GARRETT HAMILTON WITH CDAA. WE
ARE ALSO WITHDRAWING OUR
OPPOSITION IN LIGHT OF THE
AMENDMENTS. ZACH SETTLED WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT. GEORGE TH¤U ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. PAUL
YODER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS, IN SUPPORT. OKAY,
THAT EXHAUSTS THE LINE. I WILL
BRING IT BACK FOR NONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO COMMENT ON. AND
SINCE I QUESTIONS VICE CHAIR.
YEAH, NO, I DON'T HAVE ANY ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS. I APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS. AND
SO WHEN WE HAVE ENOUGH
COLLEAGUES UP HERE, WE'LL TAKE
THE BILL UP. AT THAT TIME FOR, A
MOTION AND THEN, AND THEN
HOPEFULLY A VOTE. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
WE CAN RECESS SINCE WE HAVE NO
AUTHORS AND WE HAVE BARELY ANY
PEOPLE UP HERE, WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND TAKE A BRIEF
RECESS, HOPEFULLY A BRIEF RECESS
. I'M GOING TO RUN TO THE
RESTROOM.
CALL THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE BACK INTO SESSION. WE
HAVE AN AUTHOR. WELCOME, MR.
GIBSON, YOU DON'T KNOW HOW HAPPY
WE ARE TO HAVE YOU HERE. YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE, THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3085, WHICH
AUTHORIZES A MAGISTRATE JUDGE
PRE CONVICTION TO IMPOUND A
PERSON'S VEHICLE FOR A MOTOR
VEHICLE EXHIBIT, EXPOSITION
EXPEDITION, OF SPEED SIDESHOWS,
ALSO KNOWN AS A MOTOR VEHICLE
SPEED CONTEST. THIS BILL WOULD
MIRRORS EXISTING LAWS FOR
RECKLESS DRIVING, THESE SPEED
CONTESTS ARE DANGEROUS,
UNSANCTIONED, AND EVEN, UNRULY
CROWDS COME AND FORM, TO
ENCOURAGE. THEY BLOCK STREETS,
THEY TAKE OVER THE PUBLIC RIGHT
OF WAY AND HIGHWAYS AND THESE
STREET TAKEOVERS, THESE CONTESTS
ARE ABSOLUTELY DANGEROUS. AND
MOST CASES AND I WOULD SAY MOST
CASES, WHAT'S FOUND AT THESE
SITES? CONTESTS ARE WEAPONS,
DRUGS AND OTHER ILLICIT
SITUATIONS, TAKING PLACE THERE.
AND PEOPLE ARE INJURED. I, FOR
ONE, HAD A, 14 YEAR OLD YOUNG
MAN WHO SHOULD HAVE HAD HIS AT
HOME IN A BED, SLEEP AND SNUCK
OUT THE HOUSE AND AT THE
SIDESHOW, THE SPEED CONTEST,
SPEED CONTEST. THERE WAS A
WEAPON, HE ENDED UP GETTING
KILLED. THERE WAS A KNOCK AT THE
DOOR. THE MOTHER SAID, NO, MY
SON IS AT HOME. SLEEP IN THE
BED. SHE WENT THERE. TO HER
SURPRISE, HE WASN'T THERE. AND
THEY GAVE NOTIFICATION THAT HER
SON WAS KILLED. THE ONLY ONE
THAT WAS KILLED IN THAT
PARTICULAR SITUATION. AND I
DESCRIBED THAT BECAUSE THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING MORE
THAN NOT, THAT'S TAKING PLACE
EVERY WEEKEND. WHEN YOU HEAR
FIREWORKS AND IT'S NOT, THE 4TH
OF JULY. WELL, THAT'S A SIGN
THAT EVERYONE GOES TO THAT
LOCATION AND SUPPORT THOSE KINDS
OF, OF BAD BEHAVIOR. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3085 IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ADDRESS THE OVERALL
PROBLEM THAT EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S NOT GERMANE TO
ONE AREA. IT EXISTS AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THIS BILL ENFORCES A
30 DAY, IMPOUNDMENT OF A
VEHICLE, AND RESULTS IN THE
POINTS, A POINT BEING, LEVELED
ON A PERSON'S DRIVING RECORD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
DID YOU BRING ANY WITNESSES
TODAY? NO. LEAD WITNESSES. OKAY.
MYSELF TODAY. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL? DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL? DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
THAT WANTS TO COME UP AS A. ME
TOO. AND I'LL BRING THEM BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR ME TO MAKE A
COMMENT. I LIKE YOUR BILL. I
LIKE THE OTHER BILL THAT WAS
VERY SIMILAR TO IT. ALSO, I
SUPPORTED YOU THIS BILL IN
TRANSPORTATION, AND WHEN THE
TIME COMES, WE'LL PROBABLY BE
SUPPORTING IT HERE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RAN OUT OF AIR.
SORRY. NO PROBLEM, AGAIN, MR.
CHAIRMAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO THE PRIVILEGE
OF PRESENTING THIS BILL, I
BELIEVE IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE MUST DO SOMETHING.
AND DOING NOTHING IS NOT AN
OPTION, I JUST WANT TO LEAVE ONE
SITUATION. A MOTHER WHO WENT TO
GO PICK UP FOOD WAS ALSO A FATAL
SITUATION, AND WHEN SHE NEVER
CAME HOME WITH THAT FOOD, THEY
FOUND OUT HER HUSBAND AND HER
CHILDREN FOUND OUT THAT THE
MOTHER WHO WENT TO GO GET FOOD
FOR THE FAMILY WAS KILLED
IMMEDIATELY UPON IMPACT BY THESE
STREET RACERS. THE STREET
CONTESTS THAT ARE TAKING PLACE,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE I
VOTE FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND THE
PEOPLE OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR. GIBSON, FOR, FOR
PRESENTING YOUR BILL AND WHEN
THE TIME COMES, WE WILL GET A
MOTION AND VOTE ON IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
ONLY HAVE.
WELCOME WELCOME, MR. WALLACE.
GOOD MORNING. WE'RE HERE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. I. AM YOU
READY? OKAY. NO. WE HAVE A
LITTLE DELAY. NO, I'M JUST
KIDDING. YES. YOU HAVE, KB 2186.
I DO. WE WANT TO TAKE AWAY CARS.
GO AHEAD AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 2186, A
BILL ABOUT EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED
OR OTHER SIDESHOW CONTESTS. AND
I INTEND TO DO A SPEEDY
PRESENTATION. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
A PEACE OFFICER TO ARREST A
PERSON AND SEIZE THE PERSON'S
MOTOR VEHICLE. IF A PEACE
OFFICER DETERMINES THAT THE
PERSON WAS ENGAGED IN A MOTOR
VEHICLE SPEED CONTEST, RECKLESS
DRIVING, OR AN EXHIBITION OF
SPEED ON A HIGHWAY. CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS A VEHICLE SEIZED UNDER
THIS PROVISION TO BE IMPOUNDED
FOR UP TO 30 DAYS IN 2022, WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE EXPANDED THE
CRIME OF MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITION OF SPEED TO INCLUDE
OFF STREET PARKING FACILITIES,
IT DID NOT INCLUDE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO IMPOUNDING THE
VEHICLE. THIS BILL CLOSES THAT
GAP BY ALLOWING A PEACE OFFICER
TO SEIZE AND IMPOUND A VEHICLE
FOR UP TO 30 DAYS. IF AN
EXHIBITION OF SPEED OCCURS IN AN
OFF STREET PARKING FACILITY, THE
SAME AS IF IT HAPPENED ON A
ROADWAY, IMPOUNDMENT IS A
DETERRENT TOOL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO KEEP COMMUNITIES
SAFE, AND THE BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE CURRENT
VEHICLE CODE IS CLEAR AND
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
DANGEROUS SIDESHOWS IN PARKING
LOTS. I DON'T HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS TODAY IN KEEPING WITH MY
SPEEDY PLEDGE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SINCE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESS, IS THERE ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
AS A PRIMARY WITNESS? BEING NONE
, WE'LL GO TO ME TO COME ON UP.
DON'T KNOCK EACH OTHER OVER.
GETTING THERE? NO OKAY. GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO ME UP HERE,
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL. AS I
APPRECIATED THE OTHERS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD TODAY THAT ARE VERY
SIMILAR. AND, WHEN WE HAVE A, A
MORE MEMBERS UP HERE, WE WILL
THEN SEEK A MOTION AND VOTE,
APPRECIATE YOU PRESENTING. AND
YOU MAY CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANKS FOR
COMING OVER AND GETTING THIS
DONE. I APPRECIATE IT.
WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A MEMBER
THERE. I AM, WE CAN STILL GO.
STILL SO. WE CAN'T.
OH, YEAH. OH, YEAH. CAN WE DO
SOME MOTIONS WHILE YOU'RE.
SO WE'RE GOING OUT OF RECESS. IS
THAT CORRECT? YEAH, YEAH. WE
NEVER. WE NEVER WENT IN. OH,
OKAY. SO, I AM CHAIRING SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY NOW FOR THE
PURPOSE OF GETTING US SOME
MOTIONS ON SOME BILLS THAT
HAVEN'T HAD MOTIONS YET. SO
WE'LL GO TO ITEM 12, AB 2186. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION? I'LL MOVE THE
BILL. GREAT, WOULD YOU PLEASE DO
ROLL CALL ITEM 12, AB 2186 BY
WALLACE. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO. SATO
I BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE. WIENER ALL RIGHT, NOW WE'LL
GO TO ITEM 13 AB 2309. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? I'LL MOVE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. ROLL CALL,
MAYBE 2309 MURATSUCHI MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WAHAB SATO I SATO I
BRADFORD SKINNER. YES BUT IT'S
OKAY. NO WORRIES, NO WORRIES.
I'M SORRY. SKINNER A SKINNER.
AYE. WIENER. HAVE THE MOTION.
GIBSON RIGHT? YEP. 3085, 3586.
OKAY. THAT ITEM 15 AB 3085 BY
GIBSON NEEDS A MOTION. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE FLOOR. WAHAB. SEYARTO. AYE.
HØI BRADFORD. SKINNER. OKAY.
HOLD ON. LET ME DOUBLE CHECK.
YEAH, PLEASE CHECK. THIS IS. NO,
I THINK IT DIDN'T. THEY DIDN'T
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANYONE PRESENT.
ANYWAY, I GOTTA GIVE HER NUMBER
3085. NUMBER 15. SHE JUST WENT
ON MY BANK. AND STOLE AN
UNKNOWN. IT'S STILL UNKNOWN. THE
ANALYSIS SHOWS NONE. NO. THERE'S
NO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. APOLOGIES
THAT ROLL CALL ON, 15 AB 3085
SKINNER A SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
AND THEN ITEM ITEM NUMBER ONE,
AB 1186 NEEDS A MOTION. OKAY,
HOLD ON A MINUTE. SORRY WE DID
VOTE ON IT. OH, I APOLOGIZE, I
APOLOGIZE. OKAY SKINNER. OKAY,
IS THERE ANY OTHERS? ANY OTHERS
THAT DIDN'T HAVE MOTIONS YET?
MOTIONS? I THINK I HAVE THOSE
THREE. PARTIES ARE FIRMANDO CARD
IS ON HIS WAY. ON HIS WAY. OKAY,
SO WE'VE BEEN CALLING. AS SOON
AS THEY WRAP THEMSELVES. HE'S
COMING. DOES THAT BILL STILL
GOING? WHERE DID I WHAT DOES IT
KEEP POPPING TO MAKE LIFE SO I
THINK HAVING A SHORTER PERIOD
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON. IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING AND IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S
TALKING. OKAY BUT IT'S PROBABLY
CLOSING UP. AND GUESS YOU'RE
REPEATING THE DEFINITION. I MEAN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO COME BACK
IN THE AFTERNOON WITH THE VOTES
ANYWAY. YEAH. THERE'S CONCERN
ABOUT THREE YEARS. I'LL WE'LL
GET TO THAT, AND IT BRINGS UP
SOME CONCERN THAT WE DON'T HAVE
AN ADEQUATE, SHOULD WE JUST
RECESS THEM UNTIL 130? THAT'S A
LONG TIME. I DON'T HAVE TIME. HE
MAY BE CLOSING UP IN ABOUT TO
TAKE THE VOTE. DO YOU WANT ME TO
ASK ANDREW THAT? SHOULD WE WAIT,
OR DO YOU WANT NOW? WELL, I
THINK I MEAN, WE CAN. FINE.
OKAY. BUT I DON'T THINK WE'RE
STILL GOING TO WIENER IN THE HOB
IN THAT WAY. NO, BECAUSE WE GOT
TO WAIT FOR HIM TO COME BACK.
YES, BUT BUT ON. BUT IN A.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO FOR
JOHN VERY CREATIVELY. AND I
BELIEVE SENATOR SKINNER IS GOING
TO. OR IS GOING TO PRESENT TWO
BILLS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, STARTING WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL. 2106, I'M
PRESENTING AB 2106 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY, FIRST,
HE IS ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATES THE
WORK, IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFICS
TO THE BILL, AB 2106 PROVIDES
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE PREVIOUS
DRUG CONVICTIONS THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAINTAIN
SOBRIETY AND RETURN TO SOCIETY
WITH SUPPORTIVE FACILITIES,
PROGRAMS AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. THE MEASURE
ADDITIONALLY WOULD INCORPORATE
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS INTO THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE FOR
PEOPLE CHARGED WITH DRUG RELATED
OFFENSES. IN 2018, A REPORT BY
CDCR SHOWED THAT NEARLY 50% OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED FOR DRUG
RELATED CRIMES IN OTHER WORDS,
NEARLY 50% OF THOSE PEOPLE
INCARCERATED FOR DRUG RELATED
CRIMES AFTER RELEASE WERE
RECONVICTED AND EVEN MORE
REARRESTED IN A LIMITED 2022
STUDY CONDUCTED BY CALIFORNIA
HEALTH POLICY STRATEGIES. ONCE
WE'VE EMBED SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FOR REHABILITATION IN
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE, WE
GET PROMISING RESULTS TOWARDS
REDUCED RECIDIVISM AND HEALTHY
RECOVERY FOR, AND THAT'S WHAT SB
OR EXCUSE ME, AB 2106 THAT'S ITS
PURPOSE. AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND THE PAPER I HAVE DOES
NOT SHOW WHO THE LEAD WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WILL BE. IS THERE
INDICATED ON YOUR PAPERWORK A
LEAD WITNESS? NO. OKAY. I WILL
ASK. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME, IF THERE'S ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AS A
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL, WHICH IS AB 2106 BY
MCCARTY, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES. IF
THERE'S ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO, ACT AS A LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. IF THERE'S ANYBODY
JUST WANTS TO DO ME TWO'S FOR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND STATE YOUR
NAME. WHETHER YOU OPPOSE AND THE
ORGANIZATION OR SUPPORT OR THE
ANY ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
REPRESENT. THANK YOU. LIBBY
SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF CPOC CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. WE PREVIOUSLY HAD A
SUPPORT, IF AMENDED POSITION
BASED ON THE ARTICULATION OF THE
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE NOW REMOVING
OUR SUPPORT, IF AMENDED
POSITION, BECAUSE THE BILL IS
GOING IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION,
WE WILL ASSESS AND LET YOU ALL
KNOW. THANK YOU FOR Ã. IF YOU
HAVE A YES, WELL, THREE OKAY, A
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE REFORM
ALLIANCE AND ARC, WE HAVE MOVED
TO NEUTRAL AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH US. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANKS,
GARRETT HAMILTON WITH CDA, WE
SUPPORT. LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION. BUT
WE DO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE INDIGENT DEFENDANTS
MUST PAY FOR THEIR TREATMENT.
THANK YOU. HI ERIC ANDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN. AND ALL
OF US ARE NONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT, IT LOOKS LIKE WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE LINE OF PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO WEIGH IN. SO WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS FOR ME TO
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS
OF WHICH I WILL DO NEITHER. AND
SO IT'LL GO BACK TO YOU TO
CLOSE, THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTHY, I ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. GREAT. AND WHEN
THE TIME COMES, WE'LL BE ABLE TO
TAKE A VOTE ON THAT. YOU HAVE
ANOTHER BILL YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, YES. I DO. LET'S
GO ON. I'M NOW PRESENTING AB
2882. WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, AB 2882 ENHANCES
PLANNING AND COLLABORATION IN
COUNTY CORRECTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT WE MEET OUR STATEWIDE GOALS
OF REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY.
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
ADDRESSING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR JUSTICE INVOLVED
POPULATION REDUCES RECIDIVISM.
AB 2882 DOES THAT BY REQUIRING
COUNTIES TO SET GOALS FOR
REDUCTIONS IN RECIDIVISM. GOALS
FOR DAILY JAIL POPULATION, JAIL
BOOKINGS, LENGTH OF STAY, AND
INCREASING CONNECTIONS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND IT REQUIRES THE
INCORPORATION OF MORE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH STAKEHOLDERS INTO LOCAL
PLANNING. THERE'S NO
REPRIORITIZATION OF EXISTING
PROP 30 PROTECTED COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS REVENUE IN THE BILL,
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT,
CLEAR. AND THIS BILL DOES NOT
UNDO AGREEMENTS THAT WERE MADE
DURING REALIGNMENT, THE BILL
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM A LARGE
COALITION OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE ADVOCATES. AND HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. I THANK
YOU. YOU MAY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, VICE
CHAIR TARA GAMBOA EASTMAN WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2882 SINCE
PUBLIC SAFETY REALIGNMENT, THE
JAIL POPULATION HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAILS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS HAS MORE
THAN DOUBLED. NOW, MORE THAN
HALF OF THE COUNTY JAIL
POPULATION HAS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. JAIL DEATHS ARE AT RECORD
HIGHS DESPITE DECLINING JAIL
POPULATIONS AS A RESULT OF
RISING SUICIDES AND OVERDOSES.
AND NOW, MORE THAN A DECADE
AFTER REALIGNMENT, WE NOT ONLY
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT JAIL
POPULATION, BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
VERY DIFFERENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FUNDING LANDSCAPE WITH REFORMS
SUCH AS CALAIM AND PROPOSITION
ONE. THESE REFORMS ALLOW
COUNTIES TO INVEST MORE IN
EVIDENCE BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL ONLY BE
SUCCESSFUL IF COUNTIES CAN WORK
ACROSS THEIR SILOED LOCAL
SYSTEMS AMIDST THE STATE'S
BUDGET DEFICIT. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT USING EVERY PUBLIC DOLLAR
TO ITS FULLEST POTENTIAL TO MEET
OUR SHARED GOALS. WE WILL FALL
SHORT OF THESE GOALS IF WE DON'T
BRING THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE. FOR EXAMPLE, UNDER
CALAIM, REALIGNMENT CAN BE USED
AS A NONFEDERAL SHARE FOR
MEDI-CAL SERVICES. COUNTIES THAT
FAIL TO BILL MEDI-CAL FOR
ELIGIBLE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE LEAVING FEDERAL
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE WITHOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARTNERS
INVOLVED IN LOCAL PLANNING,
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
INFORMATION GAP IN HOW TO BEST
LEVERAGE THESE RESOURCES. AB
2882 ADDS RELEVANT COUNTY
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY REALIGNMENT PLANNING
PROCESS TO ENSURE INTEGRATION
AND COORDINATION IN OUR
COUNTIES. AB 2082 SUPPORTS
COUNTIES IN MAKING THE MOST
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO
MEET THEIR GOALS BASED ON THEIR
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND LOCAL
NEEDS. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THIS MORNING. I
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY, THIS TIME
WE'LL TAKE ANY, LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. HI. THANK YOU. CHAIR,
COMMITTEE AND STAFF, RYAN MOORE.
MUNI WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. I JUST
WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING
COUNTIES ARE KEENLY AWARE OF THE
RISING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES, WHICH
INCLUDES THE JUSTICE INVOLVED
POPULATION, AND HAVE ADVOCATED
FOR SUSTAINABLE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS. UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPROACH AB
2882 IS TAKING FOR COUNTIES.
THIS BILL CONFLATES THE LARGER
ISSUE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT WITH A SPECIFIC 2011
REALIGNMENT POPULATION AND THE
SUBSEQUENT FUNDING STREAM
GUARANTEED TO COUNTIES PURSUANT
TO AB 109. WITH THE SPECIFIED
CHANGES TO THE COMPOSITION OF
THE COMMUNITY, CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIPS OR CSPS, AS WELL AS
THE CCP EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE.
THIS MEASURE PRIORITIZES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
NEEDS AS IF IT'S THE ONLY OR
PRIMARY APPROACH TO ALLEVIATE
ALL PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES, BUT
AGAIN FOCUSES ON THE SPECIFIC
REALIGNED POPULATION, WHICH IS
ONLY A SUBSET OF THOSE UNDER THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION. LASTLY, THIS
BILL DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE BOTH
THE MULTIPLE SOURCES OF REVENUE
THAT COUNTIES MUST BRAID TO
PROVIDE DIRECT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN AND OUTSIDE
FACILITIES. NOR DOES IT
RECOGNIZE MAJOR RECENT
INITIATIVES THAT ARE AIMED AT
CAPTURING SIMILAR DATA AND
ACHIEVING THE INTENDED GOAL, AND
SO, AS STATED BY THE PROPONENTS,
THIS INCLUDES IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION ONE, WHICH WAS, AS
WE KNOW, WAS RECENTLY PASSED.
THIS SPRING. THE CAL AIM JUSTICE
INVOLVED INITIATIVE, WHICH IS IN
ITS INFANCY, AND EVEN THE CARE
ACT, WHICH IS ROLLING OUT NOW,
ALL OF THESE CHANGES IMPACT THE
FUNDING AND DELIVERY OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMING AS
WELL AS LONG TERM
REHABILITATION, REENTRY AND
OUTCOMES. AGAIN, WE AGREE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE A
VITAL COMPONENT OF ADDRESSING
THE RISING NEEDS OF THE JUSTICE
INVOLVED POPULATION AND THROUGH
THE EXISTING PLANNING PROCESS
AND DIVERSE CCP COMPOSITION.
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT IS FUNDED
IN COUNTIES THROUGH REALIGNMENT,
DOLLARS AND OTHER RESOURCES.
ULTIMATELY, FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE, THIS MEASURE IS
PREMATURE, DUPLICATIVE, AND IN
SOME AREAS, DUPLICATIVE. IN SOME
AREAS. AND THEN IT IS ALSO A BIT
MISPLACED. BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION, AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT SPEAKER, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. LIBBY
SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, ALSO. AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE, THIS
MEASURE, UNFORTUNATELY, IS
PREMISED ON A FEW ERRONEOUS
PRESUMPTIONS, BEING THAT
COUNTIES CURRENTLY ARE ENGAGING
IN SILOED ENGAGEMENT FOR THESE
EFFORTS, THAT COUNTIES ARE NOT
PRIORITIZING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AS THEY'RE OBLIGATED TO DO. AND
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT NOT A FACTUAL,
FACTUAL ESTIMATION OF WHAT'S
GOING ON. THE PURPOSE OF CCP
MEMBERSHIP WAS AN ENGAGEMENT WAS
REALLY AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S LOCAL
ENGAGEMENT AND LOCALLY INFORMED
AND RESPONSIVE PLANS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
PROVIDING THE SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES TO THESE POPULATIONS
NECESSARY. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
CHANGES PROPOSED IN THIS MEASURE
DO NOT ONLY AFFECT THE MAKEUP OF
THE CCP COMPOSITION, BUT ALSO A
REDIRECTION OF FUNDING AND
PRIORITIZATION, WHICH THEN
RESULTS IN A DEPRIORITIZATION OF
THE OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
UNDERTAKINGS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED, YOU KNOW, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
POPULATION IN WHICH THE CCP,
PARTNERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PLANS IS
A REALLY MULTIDIMENSIONAL
APPROACH MEANT TO MEET A WIDE
RANGE OF NEEDS. AND WHEN YOU
ONLY PRIORITIZE ONE ABOVE ALL OF
THE OTHERS, EVEN THOUGH
PRIORITIZATION OF THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE EXISTING PLANS,
WHAT YOU'RE REALLY DOING IS D
PRIORITIZING EVERYTHING ELSE
HOUSING, EMPLOYMENT, MENTAL
HEALTH, COMMUNITY SAFETY, ETC.
AND THAT SIMPLY WAS NOT THE
PURPOSE OF THE 2011 REALIGNMENT.
IT WASN'T THE PURPOSE OF CCP
UNDER 2011 REALIGNMENT, WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO DEVELOPING
LOCAL PLANS THAT ADDRESS
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED, NOT JUST ONE
FUNCTIONALITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING. OKAY. AT THIS
TIME, WE'LL TAKE METOOS IF YOU
COME ON UP, NAME ORGANIZATION,
YOU REPRESENT ONE. NO, I'M JUST
KIDDING. IF YOU HAVE MORE, YOU
CAN DO THAT. ERIC ROBERSON, ON
BEHALF OF VERA INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE, CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ED LITTLE, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR. LITTLE.
KATRINA REECE WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. JOSH GOGER,
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE COUNTIES OF
VENTURA, RIVERSIDE, SANTA
BARBARA, AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALL OPPOSED. THANKS KEISHA HUNT
HERE WITH NOSSAMAN WITH THE
COUNTY OF MONTEREY, BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
VICTOR RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA AND LAKE COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
OPPOSITION. JUAN ANTONIO GOVEA
ON BEHALF OF THE BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
PAUL YODER, ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTIES OF SAN LUIS OBISPO,
KERN, MENDOCINO, SHASTA, SOLANO,
MADERA, AND SAN JOAQUIN, ALL IN
OPPOSITION, APPRECIATED THE
POSITIVE CONVERSATION. JUST NOW.
OUT IN THE HALLWAY WITH THE
SPONSORS. LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DIALOG DURING THE
RECESS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL, HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY, FOR
TESTIFYING AND WEIGHING IN,
THAT'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. SENATOR WIENER, DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS? YOU HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL ALL
RIGHT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. AYE. VOTE ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK FOR A VOTE.
GO AHEAD AND CALL ROLL ITEM 11,
AB 2882. MOTION BY MCCARTY.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO. NO.
SATO. NO BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER. WIENER.
AYE YOU OPEN THE ROLL ON AB
2106. MOTION. MOTION FIRST.
YEAH. WE NEED A MOTION. 2020
106. NEEDS A MOTION. THE OTHER
MCCARTY BILL. OKAY, OKAY. AB
2106 MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SEYARTO
NOT VOTING. SATO. NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. I AM. MY
GEAR. YES SO I THINK SO. YOU'RE
NOT WATCHING? THANK YOU. BY
LISTENING TO THE KI¾M KI¾M. HE'S
ON HIS WAY. ARE YOU READY? YEAH,
YEAH. LET ME. TRÊN. GOOD TO MEET
YOU. WE'LL BE INTERPRETING. YES.
I'LL BE VERY SOON FOR SURE. I
WANT TO SEE HIM. THIS WEEKEND.
OH. VERY GOOD. EVERYTHING. YEAH,
I DID.
ALL RIGHT. I HAVE THE GAVEL. I'M
CHAIRING PUBLIC SAFETY. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A MOTION. DO WE
NEED A MOTION? WE HAVE MOTIONS
ON ALL THE BILLS. SO NOW WE'RE
JUST GOING TO LIFT CALLS. WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER ONE. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 1186, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 1. BRADFORD
SKINNER I MEAN, SORRY. WIENER
WIENER. AYE THAT BILL NOW HAS 2
TO 1. 2 TO 1. IT'S STAYING ON
CALL. WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB 544, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. 544. BRIAN.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 1. BRADFORD. WIENER WIENER.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT VOTE WILL
STAY ON CALL, BILL RATHER WILL
NOW GO TO ITEM THREE AB 1799.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HB 1799 JACKSON. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. BRADFORD
WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB 2042, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB 2042 JACKSON MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 0. BRADFORD
SKINNER. WIENER. AYE. WIENER
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL
STAY ON CALL. WE'LL NOW GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 1962, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB 1962
BY BERMAN. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL ALSO
STAY ON CALL. WE'LL NOW GO TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 1978. LET'S
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS A.B 1978
BY SANCHEZ. MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
1 TO 0. WAHAB BRADFORD. SKINNER.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL WILL ALSO STAY ON CALL
. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM SEVEN AB
2064 AB 2064 JONES SAWYER.
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. WIENER WIENER. AYE ALL
RIGHT. AB 2064. THE FINAL VOTE
IS 4 TO 1. AND THE BILL IS OUT,
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM EIGHT AB
3108. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AB 30 108 JONES SAWYER.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 0. WAHAB BRADFORD.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL WILL STAY ON CALL, BUT
WE WILL GO TO. OKAY. I ALREADY
LOST MY. OH ITEM NINE AB 2099,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB 2099 BAUER-KAHAN MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
1 TO 0. WAHAB BRADFORD WIENER
WIENER. AYE ALL RIGHT. WE'LL NOW
GO TO AB NOT ITEM TEN AB 2106 AB
20. YEAH. GO AHEAD. 2106
MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WAHAB
AND BRADFORD. OKAY, THAT'S BILL
RIGHT. THAT BILL STAYS ON CALL.
WILL NOW GO TO AB 2882. NEITHER
OF YOU ARE HERE. THERE'S NO
POINT TO CALL THOSE ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY? WE'LL JUST HOLD
ON THAT ONE BECAUSE THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AREN'T HERE. WE'LL GO TO
ITEM 12 AND AB 2186, AB 2186
WALLACE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. WAHAB BRADFORD. WIENER
AYE. WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL WILL ALSO STAY ON CALL.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM 13 AB 2309
AB 2309 MURATSUCHI MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL GOVT.
WAHAB BRADFORD WIENER AYE.
WIENER AYE. OKAY, THAT WILL STAY
ON CALL ALSO, WE WILL GO TO 15.
YEAH OKAY. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM
15 AB 3085 AB 308585 VÌ GIBSON
MOTION IS Dð PASSED TO THE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0.
WAHAB BRADFORD. WIENER. AYE.
WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL
WILL BE, STAY ON CALL AND WE'LL
GO TO ITEM 16 AB 2709 AB 2709 BY
BONTA. MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 0 TO 1. WAHAB
BRADFORD. SKINNER I SKINNER. AYE
WIENER AYE. WIENER AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL ALSO STAND
CALL, WE'LL GO TO ITEM 17 AB 20.
OH, THAT IS THE CONSENT WILL
WAIT. WE'LL GO. YEAH. WE CAN DO
WE CAN DO CONSENT. OKAY. WE'LL
NOW DO CONSENT. CALENDAR IS TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT. CORRECT YES.
AND, WE'LL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CONSENT ITEMS ARE AB
2807 VIA AND AB 3083. CURRENT IS
VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SKINNER. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE WIENER AYE. WIENER
AYE. CALENDARS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT, WITH THE FINAL
VOTE COUNT FIVE ZERO. NOW WE'LL
GO TO ITEM 18 AB 2959, AB 2959.
ORTEGA MOTION IS Dð PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
1 TO 1. WAHAB BRADFORD. WIENER.
AYE. WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS. STAY ON CALL. WE'LL GO
TO ITEM 19 AB 3029 AB 3029.
BAINES MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 1 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WIENER. AYE OKAY.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM 21. AB 3241
AB 3241. PACHECO. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. BRADFORD SKINNER WIENER
AYE. WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT VOTE, THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. AND I THINK YOU GUYS
ARE GOOD TO GO. SO I HAVE TO
STAY. MAYBE WE JUST RECESSED TO
LIKE 130 AND WE'LL GET SKINNER
IN VENUS. BRADFORD, LET ME WHY
DON'T YOU CHECK? WHY DON'T YOU
CHECK WITH FOLKS?
SO I'M ALL DONE NOW, RIGHT? YEAH
YES, I BELIEVE SO, YEAH. WE JUST
WENT THROUGH THE WHOLE THING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO. LET'S JUST
RECESS TILL 130, AND THEN WE'LL
GET WAHHAB AND BRADFORD BACK
HERE. 130. OKAY? BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET THEM. AND
YOU'RE DONE. SENATOR WIENER.
OKAY, THANKS. SO DO YOU WANT TO
JUST SAY RECESS TO 130? COME
BACK IN THIS ROOM. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO COME BACK. YEAH. WE JUST
I POTENTIALLY DO, BUT. OH THAT'S
RIGHT. SO SEE THAT'S WHY Þ.
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING. YEAH OKAY. JUST ON
THE PITCH, I WOULD NOT BE HERE.
OKAY WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN THIS
AFTERNOON, I RUN HOUSING, AND I
PRESENT BILLS AND THE OTHER
SIDE, BUT YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
WE'LL JUST TEXT YOU. OKAY?
GETTING OUT. OKAY? AND WE'LL
WAIT FOR.
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IS IN RECESS.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS. I
THINK WE HAVE TO START RIGHT AT
THE BEGINNING. IS THAT CORRECT?
YEAH YEAH. ALL RIGHT, WE WILL
BEGIN. ITEM ONE, AB 1186, CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB 1186
BONTA. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT. BRADFORD I THAT BILL IS
STILL ON CALL. ITEM TWO AB 544
AB 544 BRIAN. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 1 BRADFORD A
BRADFORD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL'S OUT. THAT'S 4 TO 1. AND
WE WILL GO TO ITEM THREE AB 1799
AB 1799 JACKSON MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE 3 TO 0 BRADFORD. CæA
BRADFORD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS OUT AB 1799 4 TO 0. WE
WILL NOW GO TO ITEM FOUR AB
2042. AB 2042 BY JACKSON. MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. BRADFORD BRADFORD. PASS.
SKINNER OH, GOOD ONE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL IS STILL ON CALL. NOW
WE'LL GO TO ITEM FIVE AB 1962 AB
1962 BERMAN MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 3 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD BRADFORD I. THAT BILL
IS ON CALL. WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM
SIX AB 1978 CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AB 1978 SANCHEZ MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SKINNER.
SKINNER I OH, WAIT A MINUTE.
APOLOGIES APOLOGIES OKAY I WANT
TO I AM GOING TO START THAT VOTE
OVER OKAY. THIS IS ITEM SIX AB
1978. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BILL. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AND THEN
THAT'S IT. SO THE VOTES 3 TO 0 3
TO 0. SO THAT'S RIGHT. SO AB
1978 IS OUT 3 TO 0. WE GOT TO
WAIT FOR. SO IT'S ON CALL OKAY.
WE'RE HAVING IT. WE'RE HOLDING
IT ON CALL OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO
ITEM SEVEN. NUMBER EIGHT. NUMBER
EIGHT. GREAT GREAT GREAT GREAT
OKAY. ALL RIGHT APOLOGIES WE'RE
NOW AT ITEM SEVEN AB 2064. NOW
THAT ONE'S OUT. OH I'M SORRY
YOU'RE RIGHT. WE DID THAT RIGHT
AWAY OKAY. ITEM EIGHT AB 3108 AB
3108 JONES SAWYER. MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR BRADFORD
BRADFORD I. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL
IS STILL ON CALL. WE'LL NOW GO
TO ITEM NINE AB 2099 AB 2099
BAUER-KAHAN MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 2 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD BRADFORD I OKAY THAT
BILL WILL STILL BE ON CALL.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM TEN AB 2106 AB
2106 MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. ALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER 10 TO 1 106 IS ON
CALL. WE'LL GO TO ITEM 11 AB
2882 AB 2882 MCCARTY. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. WAHAB
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I ALL RIGHT
AB 2882 WILL STILL BE ON CALL.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM 12 AB 2186 AB
2186 WALLACE. MOTION IS MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. WE'LL GO TO ITEM 13 AB
2309 AB 2309 MURATSUCHI MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WAHAB BRADFORD.
THREE I'M SORRY. 3 TO 0. OKAY.
OH OKAY. OKAY. THAT BILL'S STILL
ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. BUT THAT
BILL REMAINS ON CALL OKAY. SO
NOW WE'LL GO TO, ITEM 15 AB 3085
AB 3085 GIBSON MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 0. WAHAB BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. OKAY. NOW WE'LL
GO TO THAT. BILL IS STILL ON
CALL. APOLOGIES. AB 3085. WILL
WILL OPEN IT AGAIN WHEN WE HAVE
OUR LAST MEMBER. BUT WE WILL GO
TO ITEM 16 AB 2709 AB 2709 BONTA
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 1. WAHAB BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM 17, WAS ON
CONSENT. SO WE WILL THEN TAKE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'VE
ALREADY HE'S ALREADY ON THAT. OH
MR. BRADFORD ALREADY VOTED ON
THAT. OKAY. GREAT SO WE DON'T
NEED TO REOPEN THAT. IT IS
CLOSED AND WE WILL INSTEAD GO TO
ITEM 18 AB 2959 ÁP 2959 ORTEGA
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 1. WAHAB BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM 19 AB 3029 AB
3029. BAINES MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 3 TO 0. WAHAB
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL KEEP AB 3029 OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO, ITEM 21, AB 3241 AB
3241 PACHECO MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS STILL B
Þ THAT BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO AB
3241 IS OUT 3 TO 0. ALL RIGHT.
ARE THERE ANY YOU WANT TO RIVAS?
I DON'T THINK SO. I THINK WE'RE
JUST WAIT FOR MISS, OUR CHAIR TO
COME BACK.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE READY. PUBLIC
SAFETY IS REOPENING THE RULES.
ONE MOMENT ON ITEM FOUR, AB
2042, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB 2042 JACKSON MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
NANCY SKINNER I, SKINNER I. THE
BILL IS OUT FOR TWO ZERO.
UNTIL THE CHAIR COMES BACK.
SHE'S ON HER WAY. SHE TOLD ME
SHE'S ON HER WAY. OKAY, THEN.
JUST PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE,
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY WILL NOW
RECESS FOR NO MORE THAN 15
MINUTES. THE CHAIR IS, ON HER
WAY BACK.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 1186. BONTA.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. WAHAB I, HOB I 4 TO 1.
THAT BILLS OUT. I ADD ON TO ITEM
FIVE AB 1962 BERMAN MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 4
TO 0. WAHAB I HAVE A FIVE ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT ITEM SIX 1978
SANCHEZ. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. NO, 3 TO 0. PARDON ME.
WAHAB A WAHAB I THAT BILLS OUT 4
TO 0. ITEM EIGHT AB 3108 JONES.
SAWYER. MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 4 TO 0. WAHAB I
WAHAB I THAT BILLS OUT 5 TO 0.
ITEM NINE AB 2099 VÌ
BAUER-KAHAN. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 3 TO 0. WAHAB A JOB
I THAT BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0. ITEM
TEN AB 2106 MCCARTY. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 3
TO 0. WAHAB A JOB I THAT BILLS
OUT. ITEM 11 AB 2882 MCCARTY.
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. WAHAB A WAHAB I THAT
BILLS OUT. ITEM 12 AB 2186
WALLACE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WAHAB A WAHAB I 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. ITEM 13 AB
2309 MURATSUCHI MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO
0. WAHAB A JOB I OUT THAT BILLS
OUT. ITEM 15 AB 3085 GIBSON.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE FLOOR
. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. WAHAB,
A WAHAB AYE. BILLS OUT FIVE THAT
BILLS OUT 5 TO 0. ITEM 16 AB
2709 BONTA MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. WAHAB
AYE AYE. THAT BILLS OUT AYE.
ITEM 18 AB 2959 ORTEGA MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. WAHAB I
HAVE A BILL THAT BILLS OUT ITEM
1980 3029. BAINES. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WAHAB A JOB I THAT BILLS
OUT. AND THAT'S IT.
CALDERON NOTHING FAILED. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU GUYS, SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS ADJOURNED.